[Musik]
dienstagabend 20.15 live im zdf wir
melden uns aus berlin aus dem alten
telegrafenamt in der mitte der
hauptstadt
es sind noch zwölf tage bis zur
bundestagswahl und tier wird der abend
wieder klartext gesprochen mit rund 70
bürgerinnen und bürgern die ich sehr
herzlich begrüße dynamik
natürlich auch ihr zuhause und herzlich
willkommen dem heutigen gast bei
klartext das ist der kanzlerkandidat der
spd olaf scholz genommen
er lebt hier in stereo übrigens alle
getestet das muss man dazu sagen in
diesen zeiten und wir achten natürlich
auch auf abstand so ist dass herr scholz
das ist heute abend ihre herausforderung
hier sind wählerinnen und wähler aus
allen politischen lagern allen
richtungen auch verschiedenen regionen
hier in deutschland einige sind uns
bekannt weil sie schon mal den früheren
zdf sendungen aufgetaucht sind andere
sind dem aufruf auf zdf heute gefolgt
heute abend bei dieser sache zu machen
und wie der andere hat die redaktion
dieser sendungen entdeckt und eingeladen
zu den themen dieses wahlkampfs von
wohnungsnot bis rente von der angst vor
steuererhöhungen bis zur klimapolitik
und manches mehr da sind überraschungen
möglich herr scholz wir beginnen mit
einer frage zum warmmachen die erste
frage von uns sie führen jetzt seit zwei
drei wochen in den umfragen öffentlich
geben sie sich über diesen zuspruch
immer berührt und mahnen sich selber hat
man den eindruck und auch ihre partei zu
demut weil sie befürchten dass es am
ende doch nicht reicht wird schon sehr
zuversichtlich wie die ganze wahl zeit
über seitdem ich von der spd im august
letzten jahres als kanzler kandidat
nominiert werden worden bin dass das gut
ausgehen kann aber die ganze zeit habe
ich auch mal gesagt es geht jeden tag
darum die bürgerinnen bürger zu
überzeugen jeden tag neu auf die fragen
zu antworten die gestellt werden und
deshalb ist der mut angesagt ist es
jetzt die stunde der bürgerinnen bürger
und nicht der politikerinnen und
politiker ja heute abend haben sie
gelegenheit zu überzeugen mal gucken ob
es klappt wir legen los und zwar mit dem
themenkomplex
sozialpolitik lernen eine frau kennen
hier aus berlin die sich seit langem
ehrenamtlich engagiert
[Musik]
hallo schöpfen
buschi sachs arbeitet mit herz
leidenschaft und berliner schnauze seit
neun jahren als ehrenamtliche bei leib
und seele in berlin neukölln der verein
hilft denen die nicht über die runden
kommen derzeit so viele alte menschen
hier
die not sind und also wenig rente haben
denn das wichtig was wir machen und da
wir keine unterstützung von wo kriegen
müssen wir wird halt machen buschi sachs
lebt von einer kleinen rente und von der
anerkennung ihrer kunden
[Musik]
aber eigentlich finden sind wurden zu
seinen kunden ortet habt aber youtube
oder der top10 gemacht oder da freuen
wir uns
wertschätzung jedes
mal auf dem nachhauseweg fragt sich
buschi sachs warum eigentlich sie als
arme rentnerin sich um die anderen
rentner kümmern muss und fühlt sich
allein gelassen man ist halt keine
wertschätzung von der politik
die sagen sich laster von leib und seele
oder von
was die leute alles ehrenamtlich machen
wenn man hier umguckt die machen alle zu
viele ehrenamtlich lass die mal machen
und rob shafir pro 100 nicht mehr so
meine meinung sie ist 72 merkt dass ihre
kräfte schwinden für die zukunft wünscht
sie sich dass der staat endlich seinen
sozialen verpflichtungen nachkommt
das ist heute abend auch zürich gekommen
grüße sie und sie haben eine konkrete
frage an herrn scholz ja sie haben wir
nun gehört also erstmal schön
hüttenabend sie haben ja nur hört ich
mache und ich möchte ja noch mal wissen
wie das ob man die leute die dort
jahrelang ehrenamtlich arbeiten
irgendwelche rentenpunkte kriegen oder
irgendwie unterstützt werden vom staat
oder eine wertschätzung bekommt was ja
eben nicht der fall ist denn wie gesagt
wir arbeiten alle umsonst wir machen
nichts nur für die leute und das die
wertschätzung von vom staat fehlt uns
und nur nur die leute die sagen mensch
ich hab da mal korrigiert da man kuchen
oder so und ich wünsche mir dass die
renten punkte auch an uns aufgeteilt
werden vielleicht können sie uns zu
helfen
zumindest mal schönen dank für ihr
engagement
ich habe neulich in potsdam bei der
dortigen tafel immer mitgeholfen das war
für mich eine sehr bemerkenswerte
erfahrung was sie da jeden tag machen
das kann ich nun viel besser ermessen
das ist eine große leistung und
natürlich auch was sie emotional machen
denn das ist ja immer mit sehr viel
zuwendung verbunden man sieht auch ganz
viele schicksale die sehr sehr schwierig
sind und deshalb bin ich sehr dankbar
für das was sie machen vielleicht darf
ich eine bemerkung machen zur rente
unabhängig von ihren anforderungen die
sie gerade formuliert haben ich glaube
dass wir viel dafür tun müssen dass es
im alter weniger armut gibt deshalb bin
ich sehr froh darüber dass wir einen
ersten großen schritt machen konnten mit
der grundrente die jetzt stück für stück
eingeführt wird wo viele die viel
gearbeitet aber wenig verdient haben
dann eine bessere rente bekommen und ich
bin auch sehr dafür dass wir alles dafür
tun dass es im alter weniger armut in
zukunft gibt indem wir durch einen
höheren mindestlohn von 12 euro dafür
sorgen dass niemand der sein ganzes
langes berufsleben immer geschuftet hat
hinterher feststellte ich bin im alter
noch auf grundsicherung angewiesen das
sollte in einem so reichen land wie
deutschland nicht sein ich weiß ihre
konkrete frage betrifft ich glaube wir
müssen das für das ehrenamtliche
engagement tun glaubt nicht dass das mit
renten punkten der richtige weg ist aber
zb indem wir dafür sorge tragen dass die
ehrenamtspauschale immer ordentlich
angepasst wird für bestimmte engagement
die dort möglich sind wenn dort
finanzielle beiträge geleistet werden
können indem wir all den vereinen helfen
den was machen und ich glaube auch dass
es gut wäre wenn vor ort aktivitäten
unterstützt werden manchmal hilft es ja
dann auch dass man den öffentlichen
verkehr leichter benutzen kann als das
heute der fall ist und da wünsche ich
mir auch dass kommunen länder zusammen
mit dem bund versuchen regelung zu
finden die solche ehrenamtlichen
aktivitäten leichter machen jedenfalls
bin ich sehr dankbar für das was sie
machen und unsere ganze gesellschaft
würde ohne frauen wie sie nicht
funktionieren
richtig dankeschön
wie kommt man zu recht auch mit wenig
geld der fokus unseres nächsten gastes
dustin albrecht geht ein bisschen eine
andere richtung er hat anmerkungen und
fragen zum zur arbeit der jobcenter er
sitzt da drüben das den albrecht ist
gekommen und sie richten ihre frage an
olaf scholz guten abend liebe olaf ich
bin selber seit einiger zeit mitglied
der spd und habe dich auch beim suchen
das gespräch in leipzig bereits auf die
thematik angesprochen und mir persönlich
fällt es auf dass die menschen in
deutschland ganz ganz große probleme mit
dem jobcenter haben sie bekommen
leistungen gestrichen ohne grund sie
bekommen wenig vertrauen in das
jobcenter und du weißt selber durch die
agenda 2010 ist eine menge vertrauen in
die politik verloren gegangen bei der
bürgerinnen und meine frage ist einfach
was möchtest du in zukunft tun damit die
menschen einfach wieder vertrauen in das
jobcenter finden und was möchtest du tun
damit auch die menschen ja nicht mal so
abhängig vom jobcenter sind sondern
einfach auch wieder ein stück mehr
vertrauen auch in das ganze finden
können und in die politik natürlich das
ist auch ganz wichtig ich finde das ein
ganz wichtiges thema und jetzt in der
kroner krise haben wir das ja noch mal
neu gemerkt da sind ja viele auf die
unterstützungsleistung dann doch einmal
eine zeit lang angewiesen gewesen trotz
der vielen milliarden die wir auf den
weg gebracht haben unternehmen und
betriebe zu retten sind immer auch
welche in die situation gekommen dass
sie am ende auf diese letzte leistung
die der staat zur verfügung steht stellt
angewiesen waren und deshalb ist mein
plan dass wir das was wir heute an
leistung haben ersetzen durch ein
bürgergeld das zugewandter ist das davon
ausgeht dass wir alle wenn wir als
bürger und bürger alles richtig mache
aber doch einmal in eine solche
situation geraten das gefühl haben das
ist genau richtig auch für uns die wir
immer fleißig waren die wir uns immer
angestrengt haben die wir uns immer mühe
gegeben haben das habe ich auch gemerkt
viele haben gesagt wieso für mich ist
das doch gar nicht gedacht aber
vielleicht ist das der moment wo wir
eine ganz große reform zustande kriegen
können für die es dann nicht nur eine
gesetzgebungs mehrheit gibt sondern wo
auch die bürgern und bürger sagen das
ist richtig wir haben ja sagen
ausprobiert zum beispiel das nicht
gleich geguckt wird ist die wohnung zu
groß dass das vermögen besser geschützte
dass die altersvorsorge besser geschützt
bei den selbstständigen haben wir
möglich gemacht dass sie weiter das
aufrechterhalten können was sie gemacht
haben selbst wenn es denn dieser kroner
zeit wenig gebracht hat und ich finde
das sind prinzipien den für die zukunft
eine größere rolle spielen müssen dass
man sich gefördert unterstützt fühlt in
einer situation in der man sonst keine
unterstützung mehr hat und ein ziel muss
natürlich auch sein dass wir alles dafür
tun dass jemand der auf diese hilfe
angewiesen es möglichst schnell da auch
wieder rauskommt dass wir also angebote
machen wie man zum beispiel durch
qualifizierung aber auch durch eine sehr
gute arbeitsplatz vermittlung eine
chance vielleicht an anderer stelle
weiter zu machen und auf eigenen füßen
zu stehen ich muss aber auch sagen dass
das bürgern geld natürlich noch eine
weile dauert bis die politik das
tatsächlich auf den weg bringt aber was
möchtest du in der zeit tun damit das
vertrauen zwischen jobs sender und den
menschen einfach wiederhergestellt war
das ist natürlich noch ein langer weg
bis das bürgergeld schlussendlich auf
den weg gebracht wird aber was möchtest
du genau in dieser zeit tun weil ich
erlebe es immer wieder persönlich dass
das jobcenter mit leistungen streicht
die man zu stehen keine ahnung schikane
würde ich jetzt einfach mal sagen oder
darf so viel papierkram ist wo man sich
einfach fragt wie ist das möglich warum
ist das so und was möchtest du als
künftiger bundeskanzler wirklich auch
konkret dagegen tun also zunächst mal
ist das ja eine große reform von der ich
aber nicht glaube dass sie so lange
dauert das man denkt das ist jetzt ewig
lange hin das muss gleich angepackt
werden und dazu gibt es ja auch sehr
konkrete vorarbeiten und ansonsten muss
natürlich jeden tag in der arbeit dafür
gesorgt werden dass die einstellung da
ist aber dass auch die mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiter genügend kolleginnen und
kollegen haben damit sie auch sich
zugewandt mit dem einzelnen problem dem
einzelnen fall auseinandersetzen können
was uns auch immer hilft an dieser
stelle wie an vielen vielen anderen ist
dass wir die möglichkeiten nutzen die zb
mit der digitalisierung verbunden sind
da sind ja andere länder viel besser als
deutschland und es gibt zum beispiel so
ein prinzip in einigen ländern die
lautet das lautet wenn man eine eingabe
angabe dem staat gegenüber gemacht hat
muss man sie nicht immer wieder machen
das nervt ja ganz viele dass sie immer
wieder das gleiche gefragt werden das
ist bei uns jetzt demnächst auch möglich
dazu haben wir die rechtlichen
voraussetzungen geschaffen wenn man sagt
ich bin damit einverstanden dass die
behörde ab fragt bei den anderen ob sie
die daten schon haben dann muss man das
nicht jedes mal wieder sagen und das
wird glaube ich eine riesige entlastung
für viele sein und auch in diesem fall
reicht vielen dank herr scholz wir
wollen ja dass auch in dieser runde
möglichst viele zu wort kommen wir sind
bei dem thema soziales wirtschaft wir
fahren natürlich auch was wird aus ihrem
geld also wenn sie sich melden wollen
wenn sie fragen haben zeigen sie es
ruhig mit der hand nach oben da meldet
sich eine dame am rand bitte sehr wenn
sie sich kurz vorstellen woher kommen
sie was ist ihre frage mein name ist
sabine müller ich komme aus teltow
brandenburg kennen sie ja bestimmt
worden
ja
und ich bin wirecard geschädigte also
ich habe fünf kinder großgezogen viel
gearbeitet geld gespart und dachte ich
was macht jetzt mit dem gesparten kosten
bayer kart wii ja viel von den
politikern gelobt und reklame gemacht
meine frage geht dahin also im januar
2009 10 haben journalisten von
financial times
unregelmäßigkeiten und geldwäsche
aufgedeckt bei wirecard und gegen diese
journalisten wurde strafantrag gestellt
von bafin jetzt meine frage an sie herr
scholz warum sind sie der sache nicht
nachgegangen warum haben sie nicht
weiter recherchiert was da los ist
stattdessen sind menschen weiter in ihr
unglück gerannt haben noch weiter
gekauft haus und hof verkauft um
wirecard zu kaufen und das finde ich
eine katastrophe
das ist ganz schlimm was da passiert ist
das will ich einfach mal sagen das ein
ganz ganz großer betrug gewesen wo
zahlen erfunden worden sind von der
unternehmensleitung was einnahmen
betrifft die soweit man das jetzt
beurteilen kann alle nie existiert haben
so was ähnliches hat es auch in anderen
staaten gegeben den usa hieß der große
fall mal in ronda waren ähnliche
katastrophen mit verbunden und das was
da passiert das haben wir jetzt auch
erlebt jedes jahr würden diese
unternehmen von wirtschaftsprüfern
geprüft mit ganz vielen männern und
frauen sind die da und die haben nichts
gesehen und nichts raus gefunden und das
finde ich ein ganz ganz schlimmes
schlimme feststellung weil das ja etwas
ist wo wir alle darauf vertrauen dass
wenn unternehmen geprüft werden
diejenigen die das machen das so machen
dass sie solche sachen sehen haben sie
aber nicht und jetzt ist die frage was
machen wir da aus meiner sicht gibt es
ganz klare konsequenzen zu ziehen und
die haben wir auch gezogen mit großer
großer härte eine zum beispiel lautet
dass die wirtschaftsprüfer nicht so
lange bei dem gleichen unternehmen
bleiben dürfen damit die sich nicht
aneinander gewöhnen das zweite was wir
gemacht haben ist das prüfungsleistung
und beratungsleistung von solchen
wirtschaftsprüfern getrennter werden
damit es nicht passiert dass man das
eine gute geschäft hat jemand heimlich
denkt vielleicht mache ich das irgendwie
anders dann haben wir dafür gesorgt dass
die haftung der wirtschaftsprüfer größer
wird und auch derjenigen die unternehmen
falsche angaben machen und haben
gleichzeitig jetzt auch die gesetze
durchgesetzt dass die aufsichtsbehörde
bafin von der sie eben gesprochen haben
jetzt mehr möglichkeiten kriegt gegen
den willen des unternehmens mit aller
härte alles prüfen kann was bisher nicht
gehen denn das was sie eben berichtet
haben hat ja bei der bafin zu dieser
anzeige geführt die ich sehr bedauere
und die ein fehler war wir glaube ich
alle mittlerweile sagen aber sie haben
auch dazu geführt dass das damals vom
gesetz vorgesehene verfahren auf den weg
gebracht worden ist nämlich dass eine
gesellschaft beauftragt worden ist diese
bilanz noch mal zwei zu prüfen die extra
für diese fälle da war aber die hatte
gar nicht viele möglichkeiten und hat
auch nicht viel rausgekriegt und deshalb
haben wir gesagt bei all den gesetzen
machen wir das jetzt so dass gegen den
willen des unternehmens mit aller härte
auch mit eigenen mitarbeitern die
aufsichtsbehörde so was machen kann herr
scholz geben doch formular die
gelegenheit nachzufragen friedlich sie
das vor schwein das bvj nicht also aus
den mieter gehen mitarbeitern es
überhaupt nichts passiert die
geschädigten die haben ihr geld nicht
die kriegen auch nichts es die klagen
jetzt aber es hat keine es haftet keiner
dafür und das ärgert mich maßlos
es gibt überall versicherungen es gibt
eine rückversicherung es gibt alles
mögliche aber die haft nicht dafür ist
doch egal was aus den geschädigten wird
das andere ist jetzt wurden die
tochterfirmen verkauft für 600 millionen
was passiert mit dem geld da könnte man
ja vielleicht den geschädigten in
kleinen obolus abgeben davon also klare
antworten zu diesen fragen erstens haben
recht mit der haftung wobei das jetzt ja
noch nicht geklärt ist denn sie und
viele andere werden ja prozesse gegen
das unternehmen führen und dann wird
sich herausstellen ob noch jemand hafte
zum beispiel die
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft oder ob
zum beispiel aus denjenigen die
verantwortung in den
unternehmensstrukturen hatten noch
welche haften und mit ihrem geld auch
einstehen müssen für das was das schief
gelaufen ist also dass die messe ist
noch nicht gesungen das muss man
ausdrücklich dazu sagen aber für die
zukunft das ist ja das was wir als
demokratische politik machen können
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass die haftung
größer ist für die
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften damit
der druck sich richtig viel mühe bei der
prüfung zu geben noch größer ist als in
der vergangenheit war denn das was ihnen
passiert ist das soll ja nicht wieder
passieren das ist ja wie bei allem
verbrechen geschehen jeden tag und wenn
die polizei aber feststellen dass ihre
möglichkeiten dagegen vorzugehen nicht
groß genug sind dann ändern wir gesetze
damit die polizei mehr möglichkeiten hat
und genau das haben wir jetzt auch
gemacht ich bin mit ihnen betrübt dass
sie ja ihr schaden jetzt nicht einfach
wieder gut gemacht werden kann aber wir
müssen verdammt noch mal wenn sowas
passiert das zum anlass nehmen richtig
harte gesetzliche reformen zu machen das
haben wir gemacht herr scholz von dem
was sie sich für die zukunft vorgenommen
haben kriegt formular ihr geld nicht
zurück wie sehr fühlen sie sich auch
verantwortlich wird das was ihr unter
vielen anderen passiert ist wir alle
haben verantwortung wenn solche
ereignisse existieren dann sofort die
richtigen schlüsse zu das system das
viele viele jahre auch viele
vorgängerregierungen zuvor von allen
immer gelobt war hat eben offensichtlich
nicht funktioniert und deshalb habe ich
mich entschlossen nicht lange zu warten
dass irgendwelche ausschüsse zu ende
gedacht haben oder sonstwas sondern
sofort eine fehleranalyse zu machen
problemanalyse muss man genauer sagen
und die probleme auch zu lösen und das
haben wir gemacht machen sie sich selbst
einen vorwurf in dieser angelegenheit
ich finde dass das was zu tun war mit
dem gesetzlichen rahmen der existiert
hat von dem unternehmen von der prüfungs
aufsichtsbehörde dafür zuständig war
gemacht worden ist sie hat nämlich
sofort diese prüfung veranlasst aber
diese prüfung war durch die gesetzlichen
strukturen der letzten jahre und
jahrzehnte nicht hart genug nicht
schnell genug und dann haben wir das
jetzt als neue gesetzliche reformen
durchgesetzt dass es in zukunft immer
gehen kann so herr scholz wir reden hier
über sozialpolitik liebe gäste hier wir
haben schon über rente geredet über die
arbeit geredet gibt es weitere fragen
aus diesem themenkomplex
ich glaube wir haben genau wir haben
einen gast bei uns nämlich matthias
räder ich glaube es aus templin der
räder hallo schönen guten abend und ich
weiß ihr thema ist die wohnungssuche und
die wohnungsnot hohe mieten schildern
sich auf ihren fall und sie haben eine
konkrete frage richtig guten abend
verschuldung machen konkrete frage was
tun sie in zukunft
das familien so wie ich mit drei kindern
zu hause eine bezahlbare wohnung finden
bekommen ja ich finde das ist ein sehr
berechtigt das thema das mich schon
lange umtreibt ich erinnere mich daran
dass ich das erste mal bürgermeister in
hamburg wurde die damalige
vorgängerregierung irgendwie geleugnet
hat dass das problem auf dem
wohnungsmarkt gibt und ich hatte
versprochen das zu ändern seither sind
in der stadt hamburg über 100.000
baugenehmigung erteilt worden und ich
glaube fast 80.000 77.000 neu gebaut
worden und das ist gelungen durch ein
großes bündnis für das wohnen mit der
bauindustrie in der wohnungswirtschaft
mit den
kommunalen unternehmen die
genossenschaftlichen unternehmen mit den
mieterinnen und mietern allen zusammen
und der stadt natürlich um hinzukriegen
dass der wohnungsbau richtig angekurbelt
wird für deutschland ist meine feste
überzeugung müssen wir uns einmal in
erinnerung rufen was wir schon mal
gekonnt haben
1973 hat mir das genau angeschaut haben
wir in deutschland west und ost 800.000
wohnung gebaut 700.000 im westen
hunderttausenden osten und wir bauen
heute gerade mal 300.000 deshalb mein
plan jedes jahr und ohne aufzuhören
immer 400.000 wohnungen bauen und
darunter auch hunderttausend gefördert
wohnung sozialwohnung weil das für viele
ganz wichtig ist wenn sie eine neu
gebaute wohnung auch mal beziehen wollen
dass die im preis so reduziert ist dass
sie sich leisten können wie zum beispiel
sie das sind übrigens viel mehr
bürgerinnen und bürger als man denkt die
hälfte aller haushalte in deutschland
hat ein anspruch auf nur ein
berechtigungsschein in den städten und
das muss sich natürlich dann auch in dem
programm die wir haben niederschlagen
letzte bemerkung weil das hier ein
großes thema ist wir müssen wenn wir so
eine große kraftanstrengung unternehmen
so viele neue wohnungen zu bauen
gleichzeitig hinkriegen dass bis dahin
die mietpreise die mieten nicht durch
die decke schießen und deshalb bin ich
dafür dass wir die mieten bremse die wir
haben bei der neuvermietung verlängern
und etwas schärfer fassen und ich bin
dafür dass wir für bestandswohnungen
sicherstellen dass die mit
preisanstiegen nicht so groß ausfallen
können wie das durch gegen gegenwärtigen
mangel an wohnungen sonst der fall wäre
also dort eine begrenzung des anstiegs
eine schärfere begrenzung per gesetz
festlegen als das heute der fall ist
vielen dank es gab eben noch einen
finger der oben war als wir gefragt
haben nachmeldungen die hand hier vorne
amtlich gemeldet was ist ihr anliegen in
bezug auf den finanzminister bzw
kanzlerkandidaten der spd und werden sie
sich kurz vorstellen bitte nicht ich bin
wolfgang kramwinkel bin schreinermeister
komme aus mühlheim am main hat dort eine
schreinerei mit 50 mitarbeiter führen
die schreinerei in dritter generation
nachfolge ist gesichert die vierte
generation ist heute abend auch dabei ja
glaubt er stolz mein anliegen meine
mitarbeiter sind fleißige handwerker
gesellinnen tischlerei unternehmen wir
haben zusammen viel erfolg in den
letzten jahren gehabt wir haben das
zusammen aufgebaut und haben den
maschinen investiert maschinen
investitionen sind auch gleichzeitig
investitionen in mitarbeiter
wir haben natürlich auch schon in den
bereich was haben die klimawandel zu tun
hat über nachhaltigkeit im prinzip her
bei uns einiges getan und jetzt
schauspiel das wahlprogramm der spd an
und höre auch aussagen von ihnen herr
scholz das massive steuererhöhungen auf
die unternehmen mal um darf bereich der
einkommenssteuer und bereich der
vermögenssteuer kommen vermögenssteuer
betrifft an für sich alle auch unsere
mittlere handwerksbetriebe und wenn ich
mir ausrechnen wenn sie auch nur heißt
ein prozent vermögenssteuer soll gezahlt
werden ist das letztendlich ca 30 bis 50
prozent das kommt immer darauf an wie
das unternehmen letztendlich gewinne
oder auch keine erzählt wenige in der
tasche das heißt wir haben wenn wir 30
prozent annimmt dass wir mehr an steuern
zu zahlen haben fehlen das natürlich
dann letztendlich
in investitionen in maschinen in unserem
mitarbeiter und in die zukunft
vielleicht mal jemand punkt herr scholz
und sie versuchen kurz darauf einzugehen
damit wir sie vielleicht noch zu einer
weiteren frage animieren könnte ja ich
will gerne sagen was meine vorstellung
ist wir brauchen erstmal damit man die
wahrheit ausspricht es wird keinen
spielraum geben für steuersenkungen für
leute die viel verdienen
das minister da noch viel mehr also wenn
zum beispiel unsere politischen
wettbewerber von der cdu/csu vorschlagen
dass man für solche leute wie mich die
leute die noch viel mehr verdienen und
unternehmen die ganz große gewinne
machen dann steuersenkungen machen
sollte die 30 milliarden euro im jahr
kosten ist das nachdem wir 400
milliarden euro schulden gemacht haben
um die krise zu bekämpfen schlicht
unfinanzierbar das kann man nicht
glauben und das wäre auch völlig aus der
zeit gefahren was möchte ich möchte
erstmal erreichen dass es eine
steuersenkung gibt für den mittelstand
für die mittelschicht in deutschland für
denen die wenig verdienen und die grenze
ist relativ hoch wir haben gesagt ein
ehepaar das 200.000 euro verdient soll
am ende dann wahrscheinlich nur sehr
wenig aber auch von entlastung
profitieren
und wenn man das macht dann muss man
natürlich dafür sorge tragen dass
diejenigen die ganz ganz hohe einkommen
haben etwas mehr dazu beitragen dass das
finanziert werden kann das wird dort
aber auch keine überlastung mit sich
bringen sondern das ist eine entlastung
zu gunsten ihrer mitarbeitern
mitarbeiter der mittelschicht und
derjenigen die noch die sehr wenig
verdienen weil das glaube ich richtig
werden aber hier geht es um die sorgen
eines mittelständischen unternehmens in
frage sagen sie es noch einmal passiert
sie sorgt die sorgen sind ganz einfach
da das dass der staat uns das geld nimmt
wo wir maschinen kaufen können das ist
sind unsere bedenken was wir haben und
das wird wahrscheinlich wieder
wahrscheinlich das wird auch ein treffen
an da kann ich ihnen ganz sicher sein
das wird nicht passieren maschinen sind
investitionen die sie abschreiben können
wir haben jetzt in der krise noch einmal
dafür gesorgt dass es sogar die sonder
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten gibt damit
wer jetzt investiert besonders
profitieren kann und das finde ich auch
den genau richtigen weg es geht ja nicht
darum dass sie für investitionen
bestraft werden sollen und ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie groß ihr vermögen ist
und wie groß ihre gewinne sind das kann
ich nicht beurteilen weil wir uns noch
nicht so genau kennen gelernt haben das
können wir gerne mal machen wollen das
finde ich aus rückblick wird auch gerne
sehen wie ihr betrieb funktioniert aber
ich will dazu sagen ich bin überzeugt
dass die meisten unternehmer betriebe
und zum beispiel auch ihrer keine
zusätzlichen belastungen haben werden
und diese aussage will ich auch sehr
konkret machen wir werden die schulden
die wir jetzt aufgenommen haben nicht
durch steuererhöhungen finanzieren das
ist nicht die aufgabe das was wir jetzt
an krediten aufgenommen haben das werden
wir durch wachstum finanzieren müssen
auch können nach der letzten krise haben
wir knapp zehn jahre gebraucht um eine
staatsverschuldung von 80 prozent auf 60
prozent zu reduzieren und das wird uns
jetzt wieder in knapp zehn jahren
gelingen wenn wir gutes wachstum haben
das hat man ja gesehen das hat sich auch
gezeigt wir haben ja auch im handwerk
knapp zehn jahren vor ohne eine sehr
gute konjunktur gehabt und die
steuereinnahmen haben ja auch sprudelt
sie waren das sehr zufrieden wenn dieses
jahr gute zweistellige millionen
milliardenbeträge letztendlich in der in
der kasse gelandet sind aber wir haben
natürlich hat das an besser verdienen
das sind ja nicht nur die millionäre was
er verdient sie haben gesagt 200.000 ist
die grenze die angesetzt ist aber das
sind unsere kunden die zu uns kommen die
sich noch leisten können sollen
handwerker zu gehen zu einem
tischlereibetrieb zu gehen zwischen
sonderanfertigung möbel herstellen zu
lassen oder küchen und da haben wir die
bedenken wenn diese leute auch das geld
im prinzip her eine sparte staat geben
müssen da haben wir nachher bei uns sagt
kann ich mir schränke machen können das
fehlt uns also da kann ich sie beruhigen
ich wäre ja selbst einer von wenigen die
etwas mehr moderat zwar besteuert würden
aber ich bestelle auch noch küchen auch
beim schreiner vielen dank für die
fragen geht weiter den rest müssen sie
wahrscheinlich dann bei dem besuch bei
dem avisierten besuch ist er eingeladen
oder
was macht also das ist die klartext es
ist die stunde der bürgerinnen und
bürger und ihrer fragen wir halten uns
ja die man merkt zurück müssen aber an
dieser stelle herr scholz einen kleinen
aktuellen exkurs einbauen zu der frage
die wir nämlich sonst ja immer stellen
was nun ja was nun herr scholz es wird
heute bekannt dass die
staatsanwaltschaft gegen ihren
staatssekretär wolfgang schmidt
ermittelt der hatte am sonntag einen
durchsuchungsbeschluss des amtsgerichts
osnabrück veröffentlicht auf twitter
dort besteht der verdacht von
unregelmäßigkeiten bei der
spezialeinheit des zolls für geldwäsche
die im geschäft fällt geschäftsbereich
ihres finanzministeriums liegt dass ihr
staatssekretär schuld sind das ist die
frage heute auch viele andere haben sie
beim trial schon geantwortet aber dass
ihr staatssekretär diesen
durchsuchungsbeschluss im laufenden
verfahren veröffentlicht hat war das in
ordnung sie sind auch jurist war das
rechtens der staatssekretär twittert
viel dazu viel kann ich kaum noch
nachvollziehen was da im einzelnen macht
und hat ein tweet versand das haben sie
ja gesagt indem er von sich aus darauf
hinweisen wollte dass es keine
informationen beschuldigten den
ministerien gibt wo gesucht worden ist
sondern dass die ermittlungen in köln
unterstützen sollte und er hat mir
gesagt aus seiner sicht sei das
rechtlich in ordnung gewesen ich kann
das nicht beurteilen da ich nun auch
andere dinge tue aber das wird jetzt
auch in einem ordentlichen verfahren
geklärt und muss auch geklärt werden
einsatz müssen sie mir dann trotzdem
noch gestatten als ich die eu übernommen
habe
2018 im märz von bundesminister schäuble
der in
der zweiten hälfte des jahres 217 wenn
ich das richtig ja immer dafür gesorgt
hat dass diese
financial intelligence unit von dem bka
zum zoll kommt waren der 160 mitarbeiter
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass es
mittlerweile fast 500 sind dass es bald
über 700 sein werden wir haben für eine
neue it gesorgt wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass künstliche intelligenz eingesetzt
wird wir haben eine neue leitung
etabliert wir haben ihn ziemlich
umkämpften verfahren dafür gesorgt dass
die fau abfragemöglichkeiten bei der
staatsanwaltschaft und der polizei hat
und wir haben sogar noch jetzt eine
unternehmensberatung längst beauftragt
die guckt kann man noch was verbessern
also das ist ziemlich gut gelaufen das
bestreitet das haben sie auch am sonntag
in trier ja ausführlich beschrieben ich
wundere mich nur dass sie das jetzt so
ein bisschen ab tun will noch mal
nachfragen das heißt er im grunde ihr
staatssekretär hat sich eigentlich um
sie zu schützen und zu verteidigen da
jetzt ein verdacht ausgesetzt nämlich
gegen gesetze verstoßen zu haben sie
sagen das muss jetzt aufgeklärt werden
und er kann auch so lange im amt bleiben
sie sehen jetzt kein grund für
konsequenzen es geht um den tweet das
muss man ausdrücklich dazu sagen die
untersuchungen die bei den beiden
bundesministerien gemacht werden um die
ermittlungen in köln zu unterstützen die
man dort gemacht hat und ich sage das
noch mal es geht nicht um ermittlungen
gegen die ministerien es sind
unbeteiligte dritte so heißt es im
juristendeutsch bei denen man auskünfte
für ein anderes befahren sich besorgt
hat diese ermittlungen finden ja auch
stadt und das ist alles sehr in ordnung
wird unterstützt und diesem fall hat er
ist das alles öffentlich geworden also
auch die staatsanwaltschaft hat die
dinge bekannt gemacht zum beispiel dass
sie vorbei gegangen ist und was sie da
gesucht hat und insofern kann ich das
nicht beurteilen ob man nach dem das
alles schon bekannt gemacht worden es
ist nicht selber auch noch mal sagen
darf er meint man darf aber das wird
geklärt und ich bin auch sicher dass
muss in einem rechtlichen verfahren
geklärt werden also ich bin froh dass
das jetzt sein danke das war was nun und
jetzt machen wir weiter mit ihren fragen
den fragen unserer ungefähr 70 gäste
hier im studio es geht das haben sie
schon gespürt um die belastung von
unternehmen die verlässlichkeit
staatliche rahmenbedingungen auch bei
unserem themenkomplex und auch beim
thema corona hier fühlt sich ein
unternehmer in eine falsche richtung
gelockt
[Musik]
textil unternehmer markus feuchter
könnte ffp zwei masken am laufenden band
produzieren er hatte nagelneue maschinen
und 2,5 millionen euro investiert weil
die bundesregierung letztes jahr
verzweifelt unternehmer aufgerufen hatte
masken herzustellen aufträge seitdem von
der öffentlichen hand 0 hier ist die
enttäuschung dass letztlich der bund ja
gesagt habe bitte produktion auf wir
brauchen das sie wollen unabhängig sein
vom kino oder vom ausland und somit
haben wir den leuten gesagt wie bekommen
aufträge das wird auch ein stabiler
arbeitsplatz werden von wegen 22 neu
eingestellte mitarbeiter musste er
wieder entlassen um etliche aufträge hat
er sich mittlerweile beworben den
zuschlag bekamen fast immer firmen die
billig masken aus china importieren wir
sind dann aber runter und haben das
versuchte eine ausschreibung zu gewinnen
bis auf 18 cent für eine ffp zwei maske
hergestellt in deutschland mit deutschen
materialien und auch das ist uns nicht
gelungen zu teuer
50.000 euro förderung hat er bekommen
für maschinen die stillstehen nur weil
die politik nicht tätig wird und nur
dass alles halb fertig denkt einfach den
fördertopf für irgendwas öffnet und am
ende gesagt okay jetzt habt ihr eine
förderung bekommen was wollte dann
eigentlich noch dann muss man einfach
sagen leute hier sei total
realitätsfremd markus feuchter fordert
eine echte chance an öffentliche
aufträge zu kommen denn erst zum
investieren aufrufen und dann billigware
aus china einkaufen das könne ja nun
wirklich nicht sein
realitätsfremd das ist der vorwurf von
markus feuchter an die politik seit er
im studio und hat die chance herrn
scholz ihre frage zu stellen machen sie
es knapp wir haben sie ja schon
kennengelernt hat wiederholt guten abend
herr scholz
wieder nach gezeigt hat sind wir
aufgerufen waren von der regierung der
sie auch teil sind und sie auch das
letztes jahr auch befürwortet haben dass
wir unabhängig werden sollten vom
deutschen vom import von schutz artikeln
wir sind dann auf drückt natürlich
gefolgt aber wie gesagt haben okay die
politik hat recht das kann nicht sein
dass wir alles vom ausland beziehen und
in deutschland kein solcher artikel zu
verfügen haben in einer art pandemie
oder im sonderfall
daraufhin hat dann die regierung sah die
voller die förderung ausgesprochen hat
man gesagt man hat sich beworben darum
man hat dann natürlich die maschinen
bestellt man hat gesagt okay wir gehen
voran das haben viele viele andere
unternehmen auch getan das ist nicht nur
mein schicksal wir haben das viele
solcher schicksale wir haben uns
produktionsbereit gemacht wir haben die
zertifizierungen durchgezogen es ist
einfach alles aufgeholt aber nur die
regierung der bund die länder kommunen
kaufen grundsätzlich in china grund wir
rufen alle hinterher wir sagen mensch
was ist los das kann nicht sein ihr
wollt unabhängig von ausland werden ihr
wollte eigene qualität in deutschland
haben eine gute qualität
nachvollziehbare qualität
und dem bei gesagt auch vielleicht vom
klimakiller vom co2 abdruck wir sind
leute deutlich besser als wenn man die
bahn von china holt herr feuchter und ja
ich weiß halt in einer entschuldigung
und da ist jetzt meine konkrete frage
was wollen sie tun jetzt in der jetzigen
regierung und auch wenn sie kanzler
werden um sollten unternehmen die sie
letztendlich auch dazu verführt haben
oder genötigt haben letztendlich
unbedingt eine produktion in deutschland
aufbauen sollen und in so ein großes
risiko gegangen wie wir sind zu
unterstützen dass man an aufträge kommt
ja erst mal bewundert ihren
unternehmerischen mut den sie ja gezeigt
haben das haben wir ja gesehen wie viel
sie investiert haben ich finde das auch
wichtig in so einer situation dass der
mut gezeigt wird ich bin mit ihnen
gemeinsam sehr betroffen darüber dass
man gar keine aufträge gekommen sind
gehe mal davon aus dass die qualität so
gut ist wie das auf den bildern aus sei
und dass sie deshalb eigentlich nur bei
den preis nicht zum zuge gekommen sind
das ist natürlich eine sehr sehr
schwierige situation und ich würde der
auch einmal konkret hinterher nachgehen
können wenn sie mir dabei helfen das
werden wir jetzt nicht mehr in der
sendung schaffen dass ich verstehe warum
das in ihrem fall konkret so gewesen ist
aber ich kann ihnen was zur situation
sagen wir haben uns für die zukunft
vorgenommen dass wir sicherstellen
wollen dass es bei bestimmten wichtigen
artikeln produktion in deutschland gibt
nicht nur mit der förderung von 50.000
euro die sie gekriegt haben sondern auch
dauerhaft in dem wir verträge mit
unternehmen schließen wollen die
sicherstellen dass wenn wir in einer
solchen situation sind die produktion
losgehen kann die überlegung dass
gegenwärtig es macht keinen sinn dass
wir eine fabrik haben in der nichts
hergestellt wird aber masken und die ist
dann drei jahre still bis man mal wieder
masken braucht sondern dass wir jemanden
und so nehme ich an dass es bei ihnen
der eine produktion hat und auch noch in
der lage wären masken zu produzieren in
die lage versetzen dass er das standby
hat damit wenn die nachfrage wieder groß
wird das auch genutzt werden herr scholz
ist das nicht ein bisschen absurd also
da bekommt ein unternehmer 50.000 euro
so habe ich das verstanden um eine
produktion anzuwerfen und dann werden
die masken nicht abgenommen weil sie
vielleicht 23 10 cent teurer sind als
die die man in china kaufen kann ist das
nicht ein systemproblem wo man auch
spürt in diesem staat arbeiten die
ebenen nicht richtig miteinander
ehrlicherweise ist das irgendwie
wahrscheinlich so deshalb will ich auch
dem konkreten fall nachgehen weil wir
mindestens was daraus für die zukunft
lernen müssen aber vielleicht ja auch in
dem konkreten fall noch eine lösung
finden können das kann ich aber hier
nicht sagen weil ich dafür nicht genug
über ihr konkretes unternehmen und ihre
anliegen weiß aber ich finde das muss
man sehr ausdrücklich sagen dass wir
schon sicherstellen müssen dass wir
eigenständige residente
produktionsstrukturen haben die dazu
führen dass wir nicht in einer krise
plötzlich abhängig sind und das
besondere hier war ja dass viele von den
dingen die man können muss in
deutschland schon gekonnt wurden also
die maschinen mit denen man das vlies
hergestellt werden meistens in
deutschland hergestellt wahrscheinlich
sind auch viele maschinen diese gekauft
haben aus deutschland weiß ich aber
nicht und das sind natürlich sagen die
eine rolle spielen deshalb muss es einen
weg geben wie das punkt trainiert
allerdings die idee war schon dass man
sagt wir geben zuschüsse damit eine sehr
wettbewerbsfähige produkte hierzulande
entstehen kann und die idee funktioniert
nicht also wir vermitteln das gerne herr
feuchter das gespräch das ist ja ein
angeboten konkretes und wir denken das
ist hier noch nicht am ende wir reden
über das thema corona das war jetzt eine
unternehmerische sicht mit blick auf die
massenproduktion aber natürlich der
herbst kommt die vierte welle kommt und
corona bleibt gefährlich deshalb wollen
wir einmal julia lange mit in die runde
nehmen sie ist krankenpflegerin auf
einer intensivstation in essen sie haben
sicherlich ja auch jetzt eine ganz
aktuelle erfahrung wie zieht das alles
wieder an und sie haben auch eine frage
und eine forderung glaube ich bitte von
guten abend genau ich bin gesundheits
und krankenpflegerinnen am
universitätsklinikum in essen größten
corona versorgungszentrum in nordrhein
westfalen derzeit
und es ist kein geheimnis mehr dass auch
die kliniken jetzt wieder sich
eigentlich auch schon in der vierten
welle wieder befinden dass die
auslastung der intensivbetten für kurve
patienten ja also willkommen an die
grenzen und auch die teams kommen wieder
an die grenzen und ich glaube auch dass
es ist auch kein geheimnis dass eben
halt vermehrt ungeimpfte patienten bei
uns auf der station liegen oder generell
in kliniken liegen und wie was glauben
sie glauben sie dass die neue erneuerte
strategie
einzug bei den leuten findet die sich
bisher nicht geimpft haben
glauben sie dass dann ja da irgendwie
abhilfe geschafft wird dass die leute
sich auf einmal impfen werden und die
kliniken
ja vielleicht vor der überlastung
bewahrt werden sie meine frau lange die
neue strategie dass man mehr beiläufig
angebote machen und angebote machen das
ist ja auch eine woche gerade eine
schwerpunktwoche ja verfängt das ist die
frage wir haben viele geimpft das muss
man dazu sagen es sind über 60 prozent
der bevölkerung einmal geimpft und sogar
wenn ich die zahl jetzt im kopf hat um
die 66
sogar schon und wenn man bedenkt dass
das ja nicht alle sind sondern dass das
gezählt wird für die 12 die über
zwölfjährigen und gerade die jugend
licht geraten jetzt in das tempo geraten
dass sie sich auch noch mal impfen
lassen seitdem die möglichkeit größer
geworden ist werden wir auch noch
weitere fortschritte machen wir müssen
aber dafür werben denn es ist weil es
nicht reicht und weil es genau so ist
wie sie das sagen wahrscheinlich werden
wir einmal im pandemie haben bei der
vorwiegend ungeimpfte in den
krankenhäusern in den intensivstationen
liegen und auch sterben und ich sage
ehrlicherweise dass es mir das herz
bricht weil ich nicht so sein kann dass
ich sagen dass ich sage die hätten sich
impfen lassen können wir sagen dass
jeden tag im fernsehen hört man das
jeden tag es ist genügend impfstoff da
morgen früh könnte jemand hingehen und
sich impfen lassen und trotzdem sind wir
ja nicht so dass wir dass wir dann nicht
helfen wollen und alles machen um das
leben und die gesundheit zu retten
trotzdem ist das so und deshalb wünsche
ich mir zum beispiel eine sache dass wir
jetzt sehr schnell zahlen
veröffentlichen die die
ansteckungszahlen die infektionszahlen
differenzieren nach geimpft und
ungeimpft und die aufzeigen wer auf den
intensivstationen nicht in das sie das
jetzt hier zählen dass viele von uns das
wissen ist ja noch nicht für alle klar
diejenigen die jetzt wahrscheinlich als
erwachsene in die krankenhäuser kommen
sind vorwiegend mit ganz wenigen
ausnahmen ungeimpfte und die sind
wirklich bedroht weil es sich nicht um
eine grippe handelt sondern eine ganz
schwere erkrankung mit viel tödlichen
folgen als dass beide grippe der fall
ist das wird alles schöngeredet und das
ist nicht richtig und ist dann nicht am
ende doch noch eine impfpflicht ich bin
gegen eine impfpflicht ich finde aber
wichtig dass wir jetzt die möglichkeit
der abfrage bei bestimmten berufen
gemacht haben wer hat sich impfen lassen
oder nicht auch damit man einfach da
bescheid weiß wie weit das ist denn das
ändert ja die situation dass jetzt so
viele geimpft sind und wir machen ja
etwas anders als andere länder wir
bleiben ja vorsichtig weil wir die
kleinen beschränkung die wir noch haben
noch fortsetzen also dass man masken
trägt in bahn und muss oder dass man
wenn man ein restaurant geht geimpft
sein genuss gewesen sein muss oder
sicher testen lassen das finde ich es
vertretbar und keine große last aldi
beschränken die wir letztes jahr hatten
aber was wir nicht machen können das
will ich ganz klar sagen ist dass wir
jetzt noch mal in einem blog down gehen
oder dass wir die schülern und schüler
wieder von der schule fern halten weil
einige obwohl es genug impfstoff gibt
sich haben nicht impfen lassen und
deshalb müssen wir alle wege suchen um
möglichst viele zu wirken wollen die
schülerinnen und schüler sprechen sie an
frau dr brunnert ist kinderärztin und
hat natürlich täglich auch mit corona
fällen bei kindern zu tun bitteschön wir
bringen mein mikro zu ihnen verwundert
ihre frage und vielleicht auch noch mal
womit sie sich täglich beschäftigen ja
hallo herr scholz mein name ist tanja
brunnert ich bin seit 23 jahren kinder
und jugendärztin ich bin seit 14 jahren
den eigener praxis in götting
niedergelassen und herr scholz ich habe
angst ich habe angst weil ich im rahmen
meiner tätigkeit noch nie so viele
kinder und jugendliche mit
verhaltensauffälligkeiten
gesehen habe ich habe noch nie so viele
verzögerungen der entwicklung sei es
sprachlich motorisch oder auch sozial
gesehen ich sehe ein unglaubliches
ausmaß an adipositas und ich sehe
immense psycho emotionale gefährdungen
der kinder wir sehen traurige kinder wir
sehen depressive kinder wir sehen
ängstliche kinder wir sehen sich
dutzende jugendliche wir haben es mit
suizidalen kindern und jugendlichen zu
tun und trotzdem das so ist werden die
kinder und jugendlichen nach wie vor
jetzt in der vierten welle benachteiligt
es gibt keine andere altersgruppe die
berufsbedingt schüler/innen
kindergartenkinder so häufig getestet
werden müssen und deswegen auch
überdurchschnittlich häufig in
quarantäne genommen werden und selbst
wenn die quarantäne jetzt verkürzt wurde
ist das etwas was diese schäden immens
noch verschärfen wird und ich kenne das
wahlprogramm der spd ich weiß was
drinsteht sie wollen die kinder
grundrechte sie wollen die kinderrechte
ins grundgesetz und eine sache die
absolut überfällig ist die wir schon
lange fordern und sie wollen das
wahlalter senken ich weiß dass es das 2
milliarden auf holt programm der
jetzigen bundesregierung gibt an dem sie
beteiligt sind aber ganz viele dinge die
da dran stehen werden ist auf lange
sicht den kindern und jugendlichen
nutzen
wir brauchen aber jetzt kreative ideen
wie wir die kinder und jugendlichen
unterstützen und aus dieser misere
heraus holen und herr scholz ich möchte
gerne wissen wie ihre aussehen dazu ja
schön
vielen dank schon danke müsse auch für
die beobachtung die sie hier mit uns
teilen weil das eine ist die ich auch an
vielen fällen dich sehr wahrgenommen
habe und die mir auch viele berichtet
haben ich glaube wirklich dass wir aus
all den gründen die sie sagen alles
dafür tun müssen dass es kein neue
einschränkung des präsents unterrichts
gibt dass wir all die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben auch weiter machen
müssen damit die jugendlichen sich
begegnen können dass sie mit im kita und
krippe gehen können dass sie in die
schulen gehen können dass sie im
sportverein ihre freundinnen und freunde
treffen weil das der einzige weg ist das
alles wieder aufzuarbeiten was sie eben
beschrieben haben das sofortprogramm
gilt sofort deshalb dürfen solche sachen
gemacht werden die sie glaube ich
vorschlagen dass also mehr
freizeitaktivitäten das
unterstützungsmaßnahmen stattfinden
damit die kinder wieder zu sich finden
können und positiv in die zukunft gucken
und wir haben es so gestrickt dass es
auch sofort eingesetzt werden kann von
den ländern und gemeinden und mein
wunsch ist dass das überall auch
geschieht weil es ist in der tat richtig
was sie sagen wir müssen das tun für die
kinder wir müssen sicherstellen dass sie
besser geschützt werden nun haben sie ja
vieles von dem was ich so nicht gesagt
hätte selbst gesagt es wird nicht wieder
obwohl das auch recht das wollte ich
sagen tatsächlich auch das von ihnen das
wollte ich nur sagen aber das ist schon
richtig dass manche dieser maßnahme
neben gemacht werden um genau das
problem zu lösen dass sie haben das
schützt und ich finde die wichtig es
gibt noch ein paar andere probleme nehme
ich an der schule beim thema corona wir
bleiben bei den kindern aber gehen jetzt
ein bisschen loch in die etwas ältere
altersgruppe und das hat sich jemand bei
uns gemeldet mit konkreten erfahrungen
aus wiesbaden wenn sie sich kurz
vorstellen und ihre frage konkretisieren
und herr schwarzer haben die ganze wirke
ich bin schülerin des anhand der carl
von ossietzky schule und beisitzerin der
ssr wiesbaden meine frage ist die zur
digitalisierung wir sind ein bereich
kona darauf aufmerksam geworden dass
digitalisierung ein sehr sehr großes
thema ist was uns gerade jetzt fehlt da
es keine gekommen ist und
allgemein uns aufgefallen dass in der
schule das sehr fehlt meine frage welche
maßnahmen müssten sie ergreifen und
diesen digitalisierungsprozess zu
beschleunigen
weil es gibt ein konzept aber wie
schnell kann das seien ja ich stimme ihm
vollständig zu dass es in deutschland
viel zu lange nicht richtig
vorangekommen und wie mühselig das ist
da was zu ändern merkt man vielleicht an
folgender tatsache ich habe den anfang
dieser legislaturperiode der jetzigen
regierung und des jetzigen parlaments
damit verbracht eine grundgesetzänderung
zustande zu bringen eine zwei drittel
mehrheit im bundestag und im bundesrat
also auch mit den oppositionsparteien
verhandelt sehr persönlich damit wir
überhaupt geld geben können für digitale
infrastrukturen in schulen damit wir als
bund überhaupt geld geben können für
bessere schulgebäude aber wir reden
jetzt über den digitalisierung wir haben
auch mehrere pakete gemacht für laptop
zum beispiel für schüler die nicht viel
geld haben für die ausstattung der
lehrerinnen und lehrer für
trainingsprogramme dass man auch die
ganze technik einsetzen kannst davon
dass bei ihnen angekommen von dem geld
haben sie das gespürt also in unserer
alten schule zu schule wurde ein ipad
endlich mal gebracht würde ich sagen
aber
etwas davon haben kann ich irgendwie
nicht sehen weil wir sind 30 leuten in
der klasse das ist sitzt zu viele leute
aller klassen ein lehrer kann sich nicht
wirklich auf einen schlag konzentrieren
ist es gibt schüler die meist nicht mal
wissen wie man überhaupt ein dokument
herunter lädt das ist ein problem ein
lehrer muss sich um jeden schüler
wirklich kümmern und so viele große
klassen das heißt zu wenig bildung da
stimme ich ihnen zu aber ich will noch
mal zudem bin ich der meinung habe mich
auch da wo ich mal verantwortung hatte
für bildungspolitik per gesetz für
kleine klassen eingesetzt es war aber
nicht da wo sie zur schule gehen sondern
weiter im norden dieser bundesrepublik
deutschland aber ich will gerne sagen
wir sind zu spät gekommen mit der
digitalisierung die grundgesetzänderung
ist erst aus dieser legislaturperiode
und deshalb läuft das auch viel zu
langsam an aber deshalb musstest du
sagen dass wenn wir zu spät gekommen
sind mit dem digital packt den wir
vielleicht vor fünf oder zehn jahren
gebraucht hätten dann müssen wir jetzt
aber weitermachen wir dürfen sich auch
führen es müssen alle schulen an das
netz angeboten bunten sei und auch wenn
corona vorbei ist müssen wir das nutzen
ich glaube dass der präsenzunterricht
immer besser ist als der digitale aber
auch ohne corona sollte es so sagen dass
vielleicht zwei drei stunden in der
woche digital möglich sind auch neue
zusammenarbeit formen zwischen den
schülern und schülern entwickelt werden
kann und damit auch alle damit so
umgehen können wie sie das jetzt eben
beschreiben dass einige damit nicht
umgehen können ist ja ein problem auch
für ihr weiteres leben und deshalb finde
ich müssen wir in diesem rahmen
weitermache und jetzt nicht aufhören mit
der digitalisierung der schulen und wir
müssen auch pädagogische konzepte
entwickeln die den normalen unterricht
begleiten wenn dann mal wieder eine
krise kommt sind wir dann besser
vorbereitet
bitte liebe das allgemein dieser
beschleunigung also sehr mir gesagt es
muss langsam langsam vorangehen die
frage ist eigentlich konkret darauf
konzentriert wie schnell ich bin dafür
dass es sehr schnell geht und
möglicherweise wenn man den
bundesminister der finanzen ist was ich
jetzt bin ich will bundeskanzler werden
aber trotzdem sitzen immer aufs geld und
stellt so viel geld bereit und das
fließt dann so langsam ab dann kratzt
man sich auch am kopf - ganz offen zu
sagen fragt sich wieso ist das so ich
glaube da brauchen wir mehr drive in
deutschland dann müssen auch viele
eigenverantwortung übernehmen und sagen
ich mach das jetzt nicht so stück für
stück ich mache das voran der vorsatz
ist natürlich auch schon lange da vielen
dank frau sie eingeht dass sie da waren
herrscher als auch in dieser klartext
sendung wollen wir nicht nur die gäste
hier im studio sondern darf ich kurz
bevor stehen ja noch mal sagen weil wir
gerade über corona gesprochen hatten
etwas vorher und über digitalisierung
ich habe ja hier so ein knopf im ohr und
es liegt mehr erklären warum das möchte
ich gerne weil ich gemerkt habe dass es
beim einem wettbewerber darüber gerüchte
gab die nicht richtig waren das haben
sie mir ins ohr gesteckt wie mir die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter des zdf
und damit sie einfach vielleicht ja dass
wir einfach mal drauf damit man uns
wirklich sein werden hier nicht
kommandos gegeben sondern es ist damit
ich zu hören kann was in dem film und
andere wo gesagt wird und das war mir
nur wichtig einmal zu sagen damit nicht
all die leute die gerne an
verschwörungstheorien glauben aber sitzt
ein kleiner mann in meinen ohren sagt
mir was ich tun soll erhalten der feier
laschet auch schon haus nicht mehr
wir hatten das in der sendung mit herr
laschet auch schon aufgeklärt denn auch
ihm saß tatsächlich kein kleiner mann im
ohr und auch glaube ich keine kleine
frau also es geht darum ist es ein
lautsprecher damit alle gut zu verstehen
sind so also stimmt von außen an der
stelle unterbrachen sie mich die wir
quer durch die republik eingefangen
haben kurze fragen und möglichst kurze
antworten von ihnen die erste hallo herr
scholz ich würde gern fragen die sie
junge leute und vor allen dingen auch
jugendliche mehr in ihre politik
einbeziehen wollen da ihre politik
sicher gerade auch sehr auf alte leute
ausrichtet also erstens möchte ich die
jungen leute mehr in die politik
einbeziehen und eine meiner forderung
ist dass wir das wahlalter auf 16
herabsetzen damit junge leute die das
wollen auch mit abstimmen können es gibt
in einigen ländern bereits diese praxis
in deutschland es hat alles super
funktioniert und deshalb möchte ich das
für ganz deutschland erreichen zum
zweiten möchte ich unbedingt dass
politik gemacht wird für junge leute in
dem wir zum beispiel dafür sorgen dass
der übergang von der schule in die
berufsausbildung besser klappt dass wir
dafür sorgen dass die
ausbildungsförderung so wird das auch
mehr leute sie in anspruch nehmen können
dass sie auskömmlicher ist das ist ja
immer weniger geworden trotz der mitte
die bereitgestellt worden und ich will
eine trendumkehr zugunsten der jungen
leute und ein thema ist mir wichtig über
das stimmt leider scheint es ist
unbedingt so dass wir natürlich den
menschengemachten klimawandel zugunsten
der jungen generation aufhalten serben
war nachher noch ausführlicher darüber
reden wir haben die nächste frage
die kandidatur gewinnen wie würden sie
zum verhältnis zu erdogan stehen die
beitrittsgespräche fortführen und wie
sieht es mit der kurdenfrage aus
die europäische union aufgenommen werden
will muss kriterien erfüllen und sind
diesen gehört der rechtsstaat die
demokratie dass man nicht seine
opposition ins gefängnis steckt und das
sind alles dinge die gegenwärtig nicht
gut sind in der türkei und darüber darf
man dich hinweg sehen und auch nicht
hinweg reden und das ist natürlich ein
thema das man im blick haben muss ich
bin dafür dass wir gute beziehungen zur
türkei entwickeln und dass wir uns darum
bemühen dass auch in der türkei dieser
prozess der entwicklung von demokratie
und rechtsstaatlichkeit wieder
aufgenommen wird aber gegenwärtig läuft
es gar nicht gut einige machen wenn wir
haben rein ich will von den kandidaten
wissen morgens politik so langweilig
dass
politik so langweilig finde das ganz
spannend das will ich dazu sagen aber
ich glaube dass das langweilige
eigentlich oft dadurch entsteht dass zu
wenig erklärt wird also ich glaube dass
politik ja nicht damit
beendet ist dass man sagt hey ich habe
ein super spruch sondern man muss ja
auch was tun und ich will gerne zugeben
dass ich sehr geprägt worden bin von der
zeit in der ich mitglied der spd
geworden bin und 75 das wird den jungen
mann jetzt erschrecken aber es ist die
wahrheit aber helmut schmidt
bundeskanzler
und was ich an ihm immer bewundert habe
ist dass er sich immer bemüht hat die
dinge zu erklären und ich finde das
gehört zur demokratie dazu dann wird
auch spannender gut wir bemühen uns ja
auch dass politik nicht langweilig ist
wir wollen aber darüber sprechen dass
sich andere viele menschen so wenige
sind gar nicht in unserem land von
politik eben auch gegängelt belehrt oder
sogar ausgeschlossen fühlen auch unser
nächster gast der gleich hier im studio
sitzt
[Musik]
michael tenzer ist renten ins in schöner
in sachsen anhalt er ist vorsitzender
eines kleingartenvereins engagiert sich
in seiner gemeinde er beobachtet die
stimmung in deutschland ändert sich
ich habe auf jeden fall das gefühl dass
ich ja nicht mehr das machen kann was
ich will also wir haben mittlerweile die
sprachpolizei und egal was es ist aber
ich auf speicherkarten gucke das
berühmte zigeunerschnitzel das ist und
bleibt für uns dass zigeunerschnitzel
nur in der familie traut er sich noch zu
sagen was er denkt sprachliche
neuerungen für ihn um erziehung
besonders wütend machen ihnen das binnen
i und sternchen beim thema gender
sozialisiert worden und wissen dass wir
unsere frauen im endeffekt auf enten
tragen und wenn ich das heute sehr dass
wir etwas sprache meinung sind wir
müssen gendern um den frauen
gibt die mehr zur geltung zu bringen
inwieweit sich eine frau noch vergangen
eine frau ist eine frau
auch seine frau monika tänzer hat wenig
verständnis ist ländern
ich habe dadurch auch nichts dass es im
gegenteil der satz wird immer länger da
sinn erlitten abgehoben in eine welt die
nicht existiert
eliten die fern von sind schöner eine
sprache sprechen die für michael tenzer
die gesellschaft spaltet
ja und der mann der seine frau auf
händen trägt und dafür nichts ändern
will oder muss setzt hier im studio herr
tänzer ich sage hat nochmal mir ist
aufgefallen in dieser sendung wurde auch
geändert nicht von uns sondern
zufälligerweise hier von ihrem
sitznachbarn und ich glaube hier die
ärztin hat auch geändert also es kommt
vor im alltag sie sind dagegen was ist
ihre frage genannt scholz guten
unterstützung mal müssen michael tenzer
ich komme aus zehn schüler bei halle und
wir wissen dass unsere gesellschaft ja
doch sehr gespalten ist dass wir
mittlerweile haben wir links gegen
rechts die eine frau alt gegen jung
haben wir gerade gesehen auch männer
gegen freunden ich habe ihr programm wir
sind ja wahlprogramm wenn ich den punkt
22 da geht es um
mobilisierten mobilität in der welt und
um die moderne mobilität da schreiben
sie in diesem dieser einen seite
schreiben sie so viel geld dass ich es
fast gar nicht verstanden habe das heißt
wenn ich wo ich fünf in der fünften
klasse war das so schlimm hätte ich in
rechtschreibung 05 gekriegt von meinem
lehrer das heißt also ich möchte hier
verstehen was sie uns mitteilen wollen
aber ändern damit können sie mir nichts
mitteilen und ich muss echt sagen die
frauen haben nicht verdient dass die im
pinken in verschwinden sondern es gibt
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen und
nicht punkten innen ich finde das ist
meines erachtens nach eine missachtung
unserer freunde und die frauen gehören
zu uns wie wasser und brot und ich sage
einfach so dass es für mich eine
diskriminierung was tun sie gegen diese
spaltung dieser gesellschaft also
zunächst mal wollte ich noch sagen weil
wir gucken durften sie haben einen
wunderschönen kleinen garten und dass
sie sich der engagieren das finde ich
sehr sehr gut ich will gerne etwas dazu
sagen ich glaube dass wir schon
aufpassen müssen die gesellschaft
besteht zur hälfte aus männern und
frauen und deshalb macht es sinn sich
darüber gedanken zu machen wie man das
auch wenn man sich ausdrückt deutlich
machen nicht zum beispiel hat mich schon
vor ganz langer zeit entschieden wie ich
das machen möchte obwohl noch gar nicht
über diese form die sie jetzt nun
aufgreifen geredet sondern ich rede ganz
bewusst immer von männern und frauen von
altenpflegerinnen und krankenpflegern
von der handwerkerinnen und
dem verkäufer was auch immer und sorge
so ein bisschen dafür dass man versteht
die gesellschaft ist eben breiter das
sind nicht nur männer die da sind und
wenn wir die wirklichkeit betrachten das
ist ja doch so dass wir unverändert noch
strukturen haben wo männer sehr dominant
sind einer der gründe warum ich mich zum
beispiel dafür einsetzt dass das nächste
bundeskabinett zur hälfte aus männern
und frauen besteht was die sprache
betrifft finde ich soll ist jeder und
jede so machen wie man das selber
richtig findet und wenn die einen mit
punkt sprechen wollen und die anderen
nicht dann ist das beides richtig aber
man kann nicht schreiben trotzdem ich
sage einfach mal sie wollen uns um
erzielt indem sie einfach sachen und
auch das fernsehen noch zdf
beispielsweise die goldene schnitzel
sondern integrieren und schätzen das
institut schnitzel muss ich ihnen nicht
sagen
beispielsweise hobbymusiker und wir
werden jetzt in portalen konzert machen
und da sind wir der indianer das ist ja
auch so eine geschichte die
normalerweise durch sein soll da hat
sich ja hab ich da schon mal ein tor
eingefangen von der anderen politikern
weil er da indianer ehrenwort gesagt hat
ich finde sie merken das schon sie
schmunzelnd zwar aber ich finde dass
ernst sie wollen uns um erzielen und
unsere deutsche sprache ist so
facettenreich und so schön darum haben
wir gute und schüler ja ich will sie
aber nicht umerziehen und ich kann ihnen
versichern dass ich glaube ich alle
bände von karl may gelesen habe und das
eine wichtige jugend erinnerung von mir
ist die mich sehr geprägt hat aber
unabhängig davon glaube ich dass niemand
umziehen sollte und das wollen auch
nicht viele sondern es geht schon darum
dass wir sprachliche möglichkeiten
schaffen und wenn sie sich so ausdrücken
wollen wie sie das möchten dann ist das
völlig in ordnung und es kann ihn für
sich ihnen versichern es wird keine
vorschriften geben es so oder so zu
machen und jeder wird seine meinung
sagen können da solltest und darf es
keine beschränkungen geben und natürlich
dürfen sie ihr schnitzel so benennen wie
sie das selber wollen trotzdem ist es in
ordnung dass in der gesellschaft andere
sagen sie möchten dass für sich anders
machen weil sie finden dass es für sie
eine form wie sie respekt ausdrücken
gegenüber den entwicklungen unserer
gesellschaft oder zum beispiel auch
beitragen wollen dass gruppen nicht
diskriminiert werden in unserer
gesellschaft und deshalb ist mein wunsch
haben sie den ich gerne formulieren
möchte
nehmen sie es nicht so kommen sondern
lassen sie diejenigen die das machen
wollen das machen niemand wird ihnen
vorschreiben wie sie das machen sollen
und wenn wir das gut miteinander
hinkriegen dann kommen wir auch zusammen
denn das glaube ich gehört zum respekt
auch dazu dass wir akzeptieren dass
jeder und jede unterschiedliche wege hat
damit umzugehen und das finde ich auch
richtig aber niemand will sie umziehen
es geht also es geht um respekt es geht
darum diskriminierung zu vermeiden in
dieser gesellschaft viel diskriminierung
erlebt hat unser nächster gast anna
corrales aus buxtehude die sich gerade
auch meldet frau cora jetzt vielleicht
können sie ihre erfahrungen schildern
mit einer konkreten frage mit einer
konkreten frage an herrn scholz wir
genau guten abend herr scholz mein name
ist hanna choral ist und ich bin
studentin und aktivistin aus buxtehude
bin in hamburg aufgewachsen und ich
möchte sie zu den rechten von trans
identen und transsexuellen menschen wie
mir befragen es gibt seit nun mehr als
40 jahren in deutschland das
transsexuellengesetz welches die namens
und personenstand änderung für trans
menschen regelt auf diskriminieren
starts und weise damit irgendwann mal in
meinem ausweis an einem hang steht muss
sich mehrere tausend euro bezahlen
übergriffige frage über mich ergehen
lassen um monatelang warten es gab im
bundestag die abstimmung darüber dieses
gesetzlich an selbstbestimmung zuletzt
zu ersetzen fdp und cdu haben natürlich
dagegen gestimmt war auch nicht anders
zu erwarten aber von der spd war ich
sehr enttäuscht von 140 abgeordneten
haben 138 ebenfalls dagegen gestimmt man
spricht immer von vielfalt toleranz und
auf ihren wahlplakaten von respekt für
allen aber in entscheiden entscheiden
den momenten wenn es wirklich darum geht
unsere rechte die rechte der community
dessen werten man sich im wahlkampf
schmückt in den gesetzen zu verankern
dann entscheidet man sich dagegen wie
kann das sein
erstmalig findet ihr anliegen richtig
und deshalb ist es so dass ich mich auch
dafür einsetzte dass der nächste
deutsche bundestag ein gesetz beschließt
wie sie das sich vorstellen weil ich
glaube dass die heutigen regeln in der
tat diskriminierend sind und sie sich zu
recht beschwert wir haben uns bemüht mit
unserem jetzigen koalitionspartner der
cdu csu zur erinnerung eine
verständigung über dieses thema
hinzukriegen das ist uns nicht gelungen
in dem sinne den wir selber richtig
finden und den sie hier auch einfordern
und deshalb will ich ihm gerne zu sagen
an die künftige regierung insbesondere
eine die ich anführen wird
selbstverständlich diese
gesetzesänderung zustande bringen und
die diskriminierung beseitigen die da
heute existieren über warum haben sie
nicht zugestimmt hat die spd in so
großer zahl nicht zugestimmt das ist
leicht zu erklären und gehört auch zu
unseren demokratie dazu in deutschland
werden regierung nicht gebildet durch
die direktwahl des regierungschefs der
usa oder frankreich sondern die
regierung werden gebildet dadurch dass
ich mir halten mit einem parlament
finden man hält sich natürlich auch in
koalitionsverträgen hält sich aus
koalitionsverträge ich finde sie müssen
auch in den momenten wenn es darum geht
ob man mit den linken koaliert oder
nicht da kann man das vielleicht offen
lassen aber wenn es um menschenrechte
geht um eine randgruppe und eine
minderheit dann erwarte ich von einem
bundeskanzler dass man bis immer klare
kante zeigt letzte woche hatte laschet
hier rum gelogen wenn es darum geht um
die gleichgeschlechtliche ehe sie können
das ganze besser machen deswegen erwarte
ich und möchte natürlich offen ihn hören
dass das vielleicht auch sogar dieses
jahr noch durchgesetzt wird die die die
ganzen entwürfe liegen schon bereit von
fdp und grünen damit hat man ja nein
gesagt und ich hoffe dass sich das
ändert
möchte eine regierung bilden ich will
der nächste bundeskanzler werden und das
wird ein vorhaben sein dass ich umsetze
gut dargestellte vergleichen an der
stelle vielleicht nochmal weil es sich
anbietet auf unseren faktencheck das war
weit gehender vorwurf den man den man
relativieren muss wir haben auch zur
letzten sendung mit herr laschet ein
faktencheck gemacht das kann man noch
nachlesen bei zdf heute und wenn das
natürlich heute auch wieder tun ja und
wenn diejenigen die die szene nochmal
sehen wollen können auch in unserer
mediathek in oder auf zdf heute auf
instagram sehr eindrucksvoll hat sehr
viele leute interessiert die frage was
passiert eigentlich wenn ein lesbisches
paar ein kind bekommt die anerkennung
kompliziert aber eindruck so vielen dank
dass sie daran noch mal erinnert haben
es gab eine weitere mord wortmeldungen
wir sind beim thema umgang mit
minderheiten toleranz in dieser
gesellschaft diskriminierung hallo herr
scholz mein name ist anastasia blätter
china ich bin jüdin und ich bin auch ein
aktives mitglied der jüdischen
gemeinschaft hier in deutschland und die
überlebende des attentats in halle im
oktober 2009 10 ich wohne in berlin nach
halle hat mich eigentlich eine
freundschaftliche einladung geführt und
nun bin ich hier und
freue mich dass sich mein zweiter
geburtstag nun bald auch wieder hier
nach dem anschlag und dass es auch
tatsächlich muss dazu gesagt werden
kein ausreißer gewesen es gab sehr viele
andere antisemitische überfälle davor
und leider aber auch danach und
seitens der politik gab es immer sehr
bestürzt rückmeldungen und ein nie
wieder und wie kann es bei uns hier
überhaupt sein doch es hat sich kaum in
taten irgendwie niedergeschlagen und
inzwischen glaubt die community diese
lippenbekenntnisse immer weniger bis gar
nicht wie haben sie das vor anzugehen
wenn sie kanzler werden diesen
antisemitismus in unserer gesellschaft
zu bekämpfen
antisemitismus ist ein schreckliches
thema das übrigens immer auch weiter
greift weil in die haltung die dahinter
steckt die greift immer auch alle
anderen an das muss man sehr klar dazu
sagen gerade der anschlag in halle hat
das ja gezeigt dass ist einer der gegen
die synagoge gerichtet waren ich war da
und hat mit vielen dort gesprochen aber
es ist eine wo dann auch andere
angegriffen wurden weil sie
in das konzept der fremdenfeindlichkeit
des rassismus und des antisemitismus
gleichermaßen in meinen passten und
deshalb darf man das auch gar nicht kann
man das gar nicht hoch genug schätzen
das problem ist es wirklich ganz
gefährlich und wir müssen deshalb etwas
dagegen tun aus meiner sicht gehört dazu
dass wir gesetze verschärfen ein paar
haben wir auch verschärft etwa was hass
und hetze netz betrifft da geht es auch
um rassistische hetze um antisemitismus
in sehr großem umfang und gleichzeitig
ist es so dass wir etwas dafür tun
müssen dass wir die bürgerinnen und
bürger ermächtigen dass wir stark sind
um dagegen vorzugehen
dazu haben wir einen demokratie
fördergesetz entwickelt das hat die
damalige ministerin franziska gefeilt
zusammen mit christine lambrecht vor
allem voran getrieben wie das aussehen
soll wissen wir schon wir sind jetzt
nicht ganz fertig geworden weil wir eben
dann doch nicht die richtige
regierungskoalition gerade haben und es
nicht geklappt hat mit unserem
koalitionspartner im parlament aber das
fertige gesetz das werde ich als
allererstes wieder einbringen und dafür
sorge tragen dass das auch was wird und
dann gibt es eine klare aussage wir
werden niemals das problem des
antisemitismus mit einer einzigen
maßnahme
verschwinden zum verschwinden kriegen
wir müssen da dauerhaft gegen kämpfen
und das ist eine aufgabe von uns allen
als bürgerinnen und bürger aber ich sage
auch es ist auch notwendig eine klare
sprache von denjenigen die das land
führen und auf die können sie sich
verlassen wie leben wir in diesem land
zusammen das ist noch das thema es gab
oben in der letzten reihe noch eine
wortmeldung bitteschön
das mikro kommt direkt
mit terroristen kennen wir uns auch ganz
gut aus auch mit opfern nur nennen wir
die gefallen ich bin christian talarek
afghanistan veteran einer von 400.000
deutschen einsatz veteran
sozusagen nur zur erinnerung wir sind
diejenigen die im kosovo die
massengräber ausgehoben haben wir haben
uns jahrelang in afghanistan beschießen
und anspringen lassen und wir sind auch
diejenigen die die särge in die flieger
nach deutschland reingetragen haben wir
kennen das alles nicht aus dem fernsehen
sondern wir waren da und ich stelle fest
dass quasi wir unsichtbar sind viele
einsatz veteran sind unsichtbar weil die
meisten von uns die bundeswehr schon
verlassen haben schon vor langer zeit
der weitaus größte teil der veteran und
den versorgungsfragen sind wir mehr
aktiven soldaten nicht gleichgestellt
daraus ergibt sich im grunde ein großes
problem dass sozusagen über die
versorgung eben zur anerkennung die
frage wie wollen sie jetzt wo die bilder
von kabul noch präsent sind dass unsere
kameraden die da waren und aber auch
schon vor zehn 20 30 jahren da waren in
verschiedenen einsatzorten wie wollen
sie die von uns erbrachten leistungen
und opfer dann zukünftig auch in der
versorgung in der politik sichtbare und
vor allem für uns auch spürbaren machen
mir ist erst mal wichtig zu sagen dass
ich weiß was für ein gefährlicher
einsatz das war über all die jahre und
das ist auch unverändert ja gefährliche
einsätze von soldatinnen soldaten der
bundesrepublik deutschland in vielen
orten der welt gibt das wird ja auch in
zukunft wieder so sein selbst wenn der
große einsatz in afghanistan jetzt zu
ende gegangen ist unter dramatischen
umständen und selbst die letzte
rettungsaktion am flughafen kabul war ja
hochgefährlich für die männer und frauen
die das dort vor ort gemacht haben da
bin ich den sehr dankbar für die
verdienen auch all den respekt und die
anerkennung für diese leistung ich finde
immer wenn der deutsche bundestag
beschließt dass soldaten irgendwo
hingehen sollen soldaten du hingehen
sollen muss das im vollen bewusstsein
geschehen dass das gefährlich ist und
das gilt für die regierung auch ich
glaube dass wir eine große verantwortung
haben und mit ihnen bin ich einer
meinung dass das nicht aufhören darf
ende dienst bei der bundeswehr zu ende
geht und deshalb muss es so sein dass
wir immer wieder gucken müssen wir die
leistung verbessern für diejenigen die
einmal bei der bundeswehr gearbeitet
haben dann betrifft es diejenigen
unmittelbar die auch bis heute unter
gesundheitlichen folgen zu leiden haben
wegen des einsatzes manchmal ja auch
weil das sie sehr mitgenommen hat diesen
partien sehr schlimmer hören das ist so
das kommt dann auch alles wieder hoch da
bin ich ganz ganz sicher und deshalb
kann unsere verantwortung nicht mit dem
ende der zeit bei der bundeswehr
aufhören das muss weitergehen und ich
will ihnen gerne etwas sehr persönliches
sagen ich war ja mal ein enger mit ihm
zusammengearbeitet mit dem früheren
partei die verteidigungsminister peter
struck der wirklich ein freund der
soldatinnen soldaten war und der mir
immer gesagt hat olaf wir müssen dafür
sorge tragen dass wir an die denken dass
wir dafür sorgen dass sie nicht alleine
gelassen werden und deshalb fühle ich
mich ihm gegenüber auch verpflichtet das
gegenüber den frauen und männern die für
deutschland im ausland für sicherheit
sorgen zu tun und dass wir dich ihnen
gerne auch zu sagen woher kommt dieses
merkwürdige verhalten herr scholz als
jetzt werden die bundeswehrsoldaten noch
mal sehr gelobt für die luftbrücke aber
als sie letzten zurückkam wurden sie
nicht mal empfangen
das war keine gute entscheidung die es
ja auch korrigiert worden das will ich
gerne dazu sagen und ich finde es muss
einen zapfenstreich geben dass der jetzt
nicht stattgefunden hat als der
einsetzen und plötzlich doch noch nicht
zu ende war nochmal soldaten nach kabul
geschickt worden sind das war richtig
aber er muss jetzt stattfinden und ich
finde das gehört dazu nach einem solchen
langen einsatz das die ehre auch dadurch
ausgedrückt wird dass wir einen solchen
empfang machen dass wir einen
zapfenstreich veranstalten alle
regierungen dafür wir wollen da gern
daran beteiligt werden wir wollen
beteiligt werden daran wir sind ja da
sozusagen auch für mich uniform nicht
mehr tragen und es gibt viele mit dem
bund deutscher einsatz veteran die sich
einbringen möchte aber in der regel
findet das sind der verschlossenen türen
verteidigungsministerium stadt und die
aber hunderttausende stehen draußen vor
der tür ich wollte nach berlin fahren
wenn ich glück gehabt hätte welche auf
höhere reichweite rangekommen zum
zapfenstreich wir stehen draußen vor der
tür wie wolfgang borchert sagte damals
wie heute also ich finde das ja
anliegen das was sie umtreibt was sie
hier vortragen sehr berechtigt ist und
deshalb können sie sich darauf verlassen
dass ich dafür sorge tragen werde dass
es immer auch um diejenigen geht die
andere in diesem einsatz gewesen sind
und dass wir wege finden das
anzuerkennen und nicht nur mit einem
netten brief sondern in leistung lust
drauf ankommt aber eben auch indem man
alle beteiligt wenn es darum geht an so
ein langes mandat wie das jetzt 20 jahre
in afghanistan gewesen ist zu erinnern
das haben alle sich eingesetzt auch die
den früheren zeiten dort tätig waren und
das muss auch gelten vielen dank auch
dass sie sich dafür so eingesetzt haben
herr scholz werden sie vielleicht wieder
hier vorne hierher kommen es gibt
nämlich noch ein paar fragen die wir in
den letzten tagen im melden sich schon
manche wird kommt gleich zur nächsten
runde reden dann über das thema klima
aber wir wollen noch mal eine schnelle
fragerunde dazwischen schieben eben mit
fragen die wir in den vergangenen wochen
im land gesammelt haben und ganz
interessanten anliegen hallo herr scholz
ich möchte gerne von ihnen wissen
warum sie nicht mit der sprache
herausrücken ob sie jetzt mit den linken
koalieren wollen oder nicht
ich habe sehr klare aussagen dazu
gemacht wie ich eine regierung bilden
und führen will es gibt grundfunktionen
des staates über die ich nicht
verhandeln will und zu diesen
grundfunktion gehört die zusammenarbeit
mit den vereinigten staaten von amerika
unsere mitarbeit in der nord- oder das
ist ein bündnis das unsere sicherheit
gewährleistet dass wir die bundeswehr
ordentlich finanzieren dass wir auch
immer mal wieder soldaten ins ausland
schicken müssen und einsätze verlängern
müssen dazu gehört dass wir ein starkes
souveränes europa haben dass wir
ordentlich mit geld umgehen dass die
wirtschaft wachsen muss und dass die
sicherheit im innern gewährleistet aber
jetzt ist es ja nur noch ein millimeter
zu sagen und deshalb kann ich nicht mit
den linken koalieren warum machen sie
das nicht und haben sie nicht angst dass
sie auch wähler verlieren wenn sie nicht
zu dieser klarheit kommt die bürgern und
bürger wissen ganz genau wer ich bin und
was ich machen werde was ich nicht
machen werde in hinblick auf die art und
weise wie dieses land regiert wird und
ich bin ja jemand der auch in bedrängten
situation wenn er hart befragt wird
schon im blick hat das die welt in
vielen themen so ist dass man
kompromisse die harte frage was erwarten
sie jetzt selbst sagen doch einmal in
eine situation wo ich habe gefragt werde
die punkte die ich eben genannt habe
sind für mich unabdingbar darüber werde
ich mit niemandem verhandeln und das
muss für jede regierung in deutschland
klar sein ich werde mit anderen streiten
über viele andere themen die mir wichtig
sind und sich durchsetzen will es wird
an der einen oder anderen stelle
kompromisse geben denn wenn die wiederum
will mir am 26 september einen auftrag
geben sollten wofür ich werbe jeden tag
weiter dann wird das ja so sein dass ich
trotzdem nicht alleine regieren kann
sondern mit wahrscheinlich zwei
koalitionspartnern regieren muss und das
bedeutet dass es auch verständigung gibt
von unterschiedlichen ausgangspositionen
aber diese fragen die ich hier gesagt
habe über die gibt es nichts zu
verhandeln nächste frage
hallo ich denke mal ich dazu sagen ich
wollte einfach nur wissen was sein
lieblingsfilm ist vielen dank bis bald
oh
je kennen sie sich weil ja gesagt hat
ich würde sagen viele olaf zum mega
rente es nimmt auch zu wenn ich das
sagen darf das finde ich sehr
interessant als ist der lieblingsplatz
scholz ich habe keinen lieblings will
ich habe immer mal welche toll gefunden
und die ändern sich dann weil ich meine
filme gucke ich leide wenn ich jetzt so
fragebogen kriege was ist ihr
lieblingsfilm ihr lieblingsbuch das kann
ich eigentlich ehrlicherweise gar nicht
sagen weil ich so viele unterschiedliche
gesehen habe und deshalb muss ich bei
dieser frage wenn ich eine ehrliche
antwort geben soll und das möchte ich
auch sagen das kann ich gar nicht so
genau sagen ich kann sagen was der
letzte film weil der korona habe ich
einen film über miles denes geguckt was
ich ganz toll fand war dass ein großer
künstler ist aber machen auch sieht was
für ein schwieriges leben da hatte neben
seiner ganzen kunst mit dem rassismus
dem rauch ausgesetzt wurde als
weltbekannter künstler gleichzeitig das
war der letzte film nicht gesehen vor
dem lange fragen eher action oder eher
romantische komödie nicht zu lesen kommt
eine ganz kurze frage herr scholz und
machen sie es auch ein bisschen kürzer
sonst rennt uns die sendezeit weg
hallo herr scholz würden sie tatsächlich
erst im jahr 2038 die braunkohle
kraftwerke abschalten ich finde das ein
bisschen spät
die antwort ist sehr klar der kompromiss
den wir in deutschland geschlossen haben
lautet bis spätestens 38 wir steigen aus
der nutzung der atomenergie aus wir
steigen aus der nutzung der
kohleverstromung aus und wir müssen
jetzt einsteigen einsteigen in die
erzeugung von erneuerbaren energien und
zwar viel viel mehr als wir bisher strom
haben die chemie industrie braucht 245
250 so viel strom wie deutschland
insgesamt wenn das alles ohne kohle gas
und öl funktionieren soll was 250 jahre
industriegeschichte lang mit kohle gas
und öl funktioniert hat dann wird das
nur gehen wenn wir jetzt im ersten jahr
der neuen regierung beschliessen
ausbauziele stromerzeugung für 245
windkraft auf hoher see an land
solarenergie leistungsfähiges stromnetz
und alle gesetze so ändern dass wir auch
rechtzeitig fertig werden so langsam wie
das jetzt vorhin sich geht kann es nicht
bleiben dann werden wir nämlich mit gar
nichts fertig das heißt sie machen eben
auch keine hoffnung dass es früher geht
als man doch es war ein ehrgeiz dafür zu
sorgen dass wir schnell vorankommen aber
es wird nicht mit sprücheklopfen gehen
da müssen bagger kommen und leitung
verlegen windkraftwerke bauen und
solarenergie in diesem land und das ist
die große aufgabe ich sag das noch mal
so eine firma basf braucht
wahrscheinlich den strom von acht bis
neun offshore windparks und eine leitung
die diese menge dann auch nach
ludwigshafen bringt und das sind die
dimensionen über die wir nachdenken muss
ein stahlwerk ein großes stahlwerk das
ohne kohle oder gas strom aus stahl
erzeugt wird in zukunft auch ein bis
zwei vielleicht sogar mehr offshore
windparks brauchen um die strommenge zu
haben die dafür notwendige es das muss
nicht immer alles offshore sein aber es
müssen diese mengen seien und das müssen
wir jetzt uns trauen zu sagen man kann
nicht als ganzes land mit der größten
industriellen kraft in europa eine der
erfolgreichsten wirtschaftsnationen der
welt sagen wir steigen aus atomenergie
was richtig ist wir steigen aus als
kohle verstromung was richtig ist und
steigen nicht mit aller gewalt irgendwo
ein nämlich in die nutzung der
erneuerbaren damit sind wir schon mitten
drin im thema klimawandel
das war jetzt noch das ja
ja also es geht beim thema afghanistan
eben gerade nicht gemeldet haben mich
schnell nicht gesehen
ich bin 17 jahre alt und komme aus
afghanistan ich habe da zehn jahre
gelebt meine bitte an sie ist da sind
frauen
kindermädchen männer die träumen ein
besseres leben zu haben die gerade jetzt
von den taliban den terroristen mega
verdrückt werden und genau diesen
momenten sie brauchen sie sind ihre
stimme wird geschlagen sie werden steckt
gepeitscht und verschiedene dinge
geschehen in zukunft noch mit dem wir
wissen alle was passieren wird wenn es
ein kleines bisschen weiter geht meine
bezahlen sie vergessen sie gehörte nicht
das sind meine landsleute und diese
menschen sind theoretisch meine familie
und meine familie hängt gerade dort
einer wichtigen situation wo niemand
ihnen hilft und sie waren vergessen ich
möchte sie einfach bitte vergessen sie
nicht
diese zu sagen ich gebe ich ihnen und
gebe sie empfahlen wurst sein was eine
zusage ist das dürfen wir nicht machen
wir haben jetzt 20 jahre so viel aufwand
getrieben und kann jetzt nicht sagen das
kapitel ist beendet und wir denken nicht
mehr dran das gilt im hinblick auf die
soldaten soldaten das gilt aber
natürlich auch im hinblick auf all
diejenigen die in afghanistan jetzt die
hoffnung hatten auf ein besseres leben
mit mehr rechtsstaat mit mehr bildung
mit mehr möglichkeiten und rechten für
frauen zum beispiel und darum haben wir
das will ich dann sagen ja zwei
entscheidungen jetzt erst mal getroffen
die eine ist dass wir all diejenigen die
wir schützen wollen nicht nur von uns
selbst geholfen sondern auch für
hilfsorganisationen diejenige die
politisch exponierten frauen die sich
für frauenrechte eingesetzt haben dass
wir denen die möglichkeit geben noch zu
kommen und darüber verhandeln wir nach
dem militäreinsatz zusammen mit den usa
und dann verbündeten jetzt dass es eine
sichere ausreise möglichkeit gibt und im
übrigen ist es so dass wir natürlich die
frage wie entwickelt sich afghanistan
weiter zum thema der politik machen mit
der eu mit der nato mit der
weltgemeinschaft um sicherzustellen dass
genau diese fragen auch gegenstand
unserer politik sind wir dürfen die
frauen insbesondere aber auch die
menschen in afghanistan die ein besseres
leben erhofft haben nicht vergessen die
dik ii hat sich das wort nochmal
genommen und das finde ich sehr in
ordnung weil das ist hier die sendung
für die anwesenden für die bürgerinnen
und bürger für die wählerinnen und
wähler sie waren noch nicht
einverstanden damit aber wir wollen
natürlich noch zu einem anderen thema
gleich kommen aber der herr da drüben
meldet sich die ganze zeit deshalb
möchte ich sie nicht übergehen denn ich
glaube sie melden sich auch gerade noch
zu dem thema aber vielleicht so knapp
wie es geht ja
und den punkt gekommen ich muss doch
ganz gut ab und herr schluss sagen hat
und ich bin auch eine ehemalige
großaktionär afghanistan in sakko schon
komisch aus heute mit meinen traum auf
see aus
ich habe mir ja und in afghanistan toten
verbundes werk arbeitet seit 2001 bin
ich mit einem visum mit meiner frau nach
deutschland gekommen dort war dann
besteht eine gefahr für mich zeit nimmt
ist verlängert
laufen hat ist es immer um ein jahr
und ich kann nicht meine zukunft planen
und
ist möglich machen das die
dass sie
uns einer dauerhaft dass er hier
dauerhaft bleiben können und unsere
unserer lebend in sicherheit langgöns
und
es ist offensichtlich nach der
entwicklung in afghanistan jetzt
eingetreten ist dass wir es recht eine
stabile aufenthaltsperspektive schaffen
müssen es gibt dafür rechtliche
rahmenbedingungen die wir allerdings
auch beeinflussen kann und natürlich
wollen wir alles dafür tun dass das
gelingt dass man jetzt hier leben sich
gut integrieren kann dass man eine
arbeit nachgehen kann dass man seinen
eigenen lebensunterhalt verdienen kann
wie sie das wenn ich das richtig
verstehe ja auch tun und dann muss es
auch eine sichere feste
aufenthaltsperspektive geben da bin ich
fest von überzeugt ich bin mir sicher
weile in afghanistan werden keine praxis
zeigt hier wir haben keine sicherheit
weil um eine verlängerung kein
aufenthaltes dauert sechs monate gernot
werfen 1066 monat machen sie ist möglich
machen sie uns dieser
gesetzesänderung das wäre hier die
andere kolleginnen und kolleginnen beim
hot club band gerade beim evakuierung
beim bundeswehr hergekommen sind wie
möglich machen machen sie der zukunft
gewisse änderung oder anderen dass die
es geht
ich habe die frage beantwortet und will
das aber gern noch mal tun ich finde es
muss eine dauerhafte perspektive geben
die natürlich verknüpft ist darin dass
sie auch lebensentscheidungen treffen
hier die etwas mit dauerhafte
perspektive zu tun haben zum beispiel
was die frage der berufstätigkeit
betrifft das finde ich ganz wichtig aber
in dem rahmen soll muss es dann auch so
sein dass sie sich darauf verlassen
können dass das jetzt eine entscheidung
ist auf der sie ihr leben aufbauen
können denn nach geht davon aus dass sie
so wie die dinge gelaufen sind hier
leben werden kinder enkel haben werden
dass die zur schule gehen dass sie
glücklich in diesem land werden und dann
in dem das auch noch das spiel wie sehr
das klima menschen die hier in diesem
land zu leben auch unter die haut geht
vielen dank dass die 2 beide dieses
schicksal noch einmal geschildert haben
wir wollen noch über den klimawandel
reden wir lassen jetzt den vorbereiteten
film ab weg um die kollegen im heute
sondern nicht nur länger warten zu
lassen aber es gibt noch zwei drei leute
die sich gemeldet haben ich hab hier auf
meinem zettel stehen und das ist ganz
wichtig weil wir ihn getroffen haben
schon anklamer diplom forstingenieur
klammer wo sind sie was ist ihre frage
an den vorsitzender hier ja
ich war 25 jahre forstbeamter in hessen
und bin derzeit auf einer 6000 kilometer
wanderung durch deutschlands wälder um
auf die bedrohung unserer bilder
aufmerksam zu machen man muss ganz klar
sagen von 2018 bis 21 hatten wir eine
dürre wie nie zuvor die wälder sind
großflächig abgestorben und wir haben
sehr viel glück das ist in diesem jahr
was niederschläge angeht besser aussieht
aber das muss nicht unbedingt zu bleiben
schon in meinem studium vor 30 jahren
habe ich gelernt was klimawandel ist
dass er kommt dass wir handeln müssen
ist jetzt viel zu wenig passiert das
sagt jeder wissenschaftler der sich
damit beschäftigt meine frage an sie ist
jetzt was sind ihre drei konkreten
maßnahmen um den klimawandel tatsächlich
in den griff zu kriegen
erste maßnahme im nächsten jahr ein
gesetz das den strombedarf deutschlands
für 2045 errechnet und festlegt damit
wir die ausbauziele für erneuerbare
energien offshore-wind wind an land
solarenergie so hoch setzen dass wir
tatsächlich unseren strombedarf daraus
decken können dazu gehört auch dass wir
die wasserstoffproduktion aus
erneuerbaren energien so anreizen dass
wir gleichzeitig auch speicher bilden
können denn sonne und wind stehen ja
nicht ununterbrochen zur verfügung es
muss also möglich sein denn gerade keine
sonne kein wind da es dass man dann auf
die speicher zurückgreifen kann und
meine permanente stromversorgung zu
gewährleisten
die industrie wird das investieren wenn
wir das möglich machen und wir müssen
dann gleichzeitig dafür sorgen dass dann
all die investitionen der stahl der
industrie der zementindustrie der
chemie-industrie stattfinden die die
längst planum klimaneutral zu
wirtschaften in ganz kurzer zeit in 25
jahren soll das gelingen und die wollen
von uns nur dass wir sagen die kriegt
den strom den er dafür braucht das
werden wir euch gewährleisten deshalb
ist dass die maßnahme und die wird
ergänzt dadurch dass ich sage wir ändern
die gesetze so dass wir auch rechtzeitig
fertig werden damit den heutigen würden
wir das nicht schaffen dann dauert die
genehmigung an der windkraftanlage sechs
jahre statt sechs monate und das musste
ich unterschätzt werden nachfrage bitte
ja bei allem was sie sagen auch zuvor
schon habe ich immer das gefühl sie
reden aus der position der industrie das
ist der strombedarf der industrie den
müssen wir irgendwie decken das ist aber
unsere lebensgrundlagen letzten endes
geht und da vielleicht doch auch mal
entscheidungen fallen müssen die zum
teil auch dann nicht zugunsten der
industrie sind das gefühl habe ich bei
ihnen nicht ich bin mit ihnen nicht
einer meinung doch muss er in seiner
sendung auch möglich sein und deshalb
will ich ihnen gerne meine meinung auch
sehr klar leute also die chemie
industrie ein wichtiger arbeitgeber in
deutschland hat einen plan wie sie ohne
kohle gas und öl zu recht kommt bei
ihren produktionsprozessen und wenn
dieser plan funktionieren soll brauchen
die strohmann stattdessen und
wasserstoff auch dass es ein rohstoff de
einsetzen müssen ich finde wenn wir das
schaffen dass eines der erfolgreichsten
wirtschafts und industrieländer der welt
das ist deutschland unverändert es
schafft industrie herzustellen die
klimaneutral wirtschaftet dann ist das
auch die antwort auf die frage wie
kriegen wir das hin dass der globale
klimawandel aufgehalten wird denn wir
werden ja die bürgerinnen und bürger
asiens in indien in vielen anderen
ländern nicht überreden dass sie auf
unseren wohlstand verzichten dass sie
keine autos haben wollen dass sie keine
kraftwerke haben wollen sondern wir
können sie ja nur überzeugen dass es
eine technologie gibt die wir hier
entwickeln können mit unseren
ingenieuren ingenieuren mit unseren
möglichkeiten auf die sie zurückgreifen
können manche haben ja die idee wir
überweisen den geld und dann sagen sie
wir wollen nicht so leben wie ihr nein
das werden die nicht machen wir müssen
den auch ab und zu helfen wenn sie nicht
genug finanzkraft haben aber wir müssen
ihnen sagen wir haben hier eine
wirtschaftsleistung eine technologie die
könnte er einsetzen die ist genauso
billig genauso wirksam wie kohle gas und
öl aber er schädigt nicht das klima und
ihr kommt besser zurecht so das war
jetzt auch schon sehr grundsätzlich
vielen dank herr scholz wir müssen auf
die uhr schauen denn eigentlich beginnt
jetzt schon das heute journal ich würde
sagen weil sich doch noch einige
gemeldet haben eine letzte frage nehmen
wir noch aus diesem themenkomplex und
ich nehme jetzt einfach hier vorne bitte
schön wenn sie sich vorstellen und dann
eine kompakte frage möglich stellen mit
in der ersten reihe hatte ich eigentlich
gedacht aber
schuldig aber jetzt habe ich die heute
statt den abend johannes gehört mein
name ich wohne in berlin und bin seit
sechs monaten vater meine frau kommt aus
den niederlanden
wir haben ja auch nach konkreten zielen
oder konkreten sachen gefragt wie wir
die klimakrise aufhalten können wenn ich
mir jetzt vorstelle dass meine tochter
in den niederlanden zur schule fährt mit
dem fahrrad in ein paar jahren fühlt
sich alles ganz normal an wenn ich mir
jetzt überlegen meine tochter fährt
in deutschland mit dem fahrrad zur
schule dann kriege ich ein ganz mulmiges
gefühl
und da geht es nicht nur mir so jede
umfrage zeigt wieder dass die ja die
mehrheit in deutschland eigentlich
richtig gerne fahrrad fahren würde wenn
die infrastruktur ist auch zulassen
würde wir haben jetzt gesehen dass mehr
leute zu ihr mit dem fahrrad gekommen
sind um für fahrradverkehr zu
demonstrieren als zu ja selber gegangen
sind
wir haben nächstes wochenende wieder
eine riesige titel mehr ist also eine
kinder demo die menschen wollen fahrrad
fahren und ich würde gerne von ihnen
wissen
was werden sie vielleicht als
zukünftiger bundeskanzler dafür tun dass
wir in deutschland die verkehrswende
frank bringen und dass wir endlich
sicher fahrrad fahren können
wir brauchen moderne mobilität dazu der
ausbau des schienenverkehrs der ist sehr
vernachlässigt worden auch was die
regionalen verkehr betrifft deshalb habe
ich die summe die dafür nötig ist schon
auf eine milliarde erhöht und wir sie
noch mal auf zwei milliarden anheben
damit endlich neue s bahn und u bahn
linien geplant werden können
straßenbahnlinien und ist ein
attraktives angebot gibt jemand sagt ich
habe zwar im auto aber das nämlich jetzt
und gleichzeitig finde es viele geben
die fahrzeuge benutzen deshalb geht es
darum dass wir die elektrifizierung
vorantreiben und auch eine gute
infrastruktur für fahrzeugnutzer haben
und wir müssen dann noch hinkriegen dass
auch für fußgänger und fußgängern und
fahrradfahrern und fahrradfahrer der
straßenraum besser nutzbar wird ich habe
mir mal ein film angeguckt der hatte den
schönen titel wie das auto in die stadt
kam und ich will sicher sein das war so
ein kleiner beitrag darf ich das hier im
zdf sagen vom ndr also und zwar
befreundeten bild also einen bericht und
kleiner bericht ich glaube aus den 60er
jahren und
ich bin fast erschrocken weil da hatten
sich noch nicht alle anderes auto
gewöhnt da sind die fahrradfahrerinnen
und fahrradfahrer so gefahren als gäbe
es keine autos die autofahrer als gibt
es die anderen nicht fußgänger sind
einfach quer über die straße gegangen
und dann wurde an dem einen bahnhof ein
schild veröffentlicht die toten der
woche und das heißt es hat sich seit der
ganz viel verändert weil wir die
infrastrukturen verändert haben aber wir
haben vergessen dass es ganz viele gibt
die nicht am wochenende mit dem fahrrad
mal in die natur fahren wollen die gibt
es auch schön sondern die damit zur
arbeit fahren wollen oder zur
universität oder zur schule und das gilt
auch für die kinder und deshalb müssen
wir den straßenraum so weiterentwickeln
dass es möglich ist sicher mit dem
fahrrad sich durch die städte und auch
durch die landschaft zu bewegen da kann
der bund helfen mit finanzmitteln auch
mit ein paar gesetzen dass sie eine
kleine stellschrauben die geändert
werden müssen aber die sind wichtig und
natürlich muss es überall vor ort
aufgegriffen werden ich bin gegen sollen
gegeneinander aber ich finde das
jedenfalls etwas dafür getan werden muss
dass das möglich ist und wenn es dann
viele tun ist das ja auch gut für die
autofahrerinnen und autofahrer denn die
fahrradfahren verstopfen ihnen nicht die
straße sie hatten die letzte frage
soweit also die fragen unserer gäste
hier im studio vor ihnen herr scholz und
für uns allen liegen jetzt noch zwölf
tage bis zur wahl entscheiden so ist es
herr scholz und zwei fahren von uns zum
schluss sie haben ja in den letzten
wochen oft den eindruck vermittelt der
echte nachfolger von angela merkel zu
sein und die ära merkel fortzusetzen
wenn sie sogar dafür zur nagel raute
greifen auf diesem foto aus der
süddeutschen zeitung ist das für einen
stolzen sozialdemokraten nicht ein
bisschen zu viel anbiederung
ehrlicherweise hatte ich eine lustige
frage für eine fotoserie der
süddeutschen zeitung wo man nichts sagen
darf sondern nur
irgendwelche zeichen machen darf man
sich fotografieren lässt und die frage
lautete was werden sie von frau merkel
vermissen wenn ich das richtig erinnern
daraufhin habe ich die raute gemacht ich
fand es lustig und es war doch klar dass
sie sozusagen ihr symbol imitieren und
damit sagen ich bin der merkel ich fand
es lustig und wie ihr seid das weiß ich
auch als als merkel 2005 kanzlerin wurde
war es ja bekanntermaßen sehr knapp es
kam dann eine große koalition dabei
heraus jetzt muss es ja nicht unbedingt
eine dreier konstellationen werden es
könnte ja auch eine zweier konstellation
reichen das will ich schon noch fragen
ist das wäre eine große koalition auch
eine option für sie
es ist jetzt die zeit wo die bürger und
bürger entscheiden und ich finde dass er
ist wirklich jede demut für alle
diejenigen angesagt die sich zur wahl
stellen ich bewerbe mich auch ein mandat
ich möchte dass viele sagen
ich soll der nächste kanzler werden und
deshalb ihr kreuz bei der spd machen und
viele haben sich da schon ja fast zu
durchgerungen ich hoffe sie machen das
endgültig und das was mir ganz ganz
wichtig ist das aber ich spüre dass ganz
viele sich wünschen dass cdu/csu jetzt
auch mal in der opposition sich neu
orientieren und ich glaube das sollte
auch zustande kommen und die koalition
darüber entscheiden sie oder die spd
parteiführung darüber entscheidet immer
alle gemeinsam aber es wird keine
koalition geben mit der der kanzler
nicht einverstanden flug das kann man ja
gar nicht funktionieren das war klartext
mit olaf scholz so weit wie möglich am
donnerstag steht dann hier annalena
baerbock die kanzlerkandidatin der
grünen wir danken ihnen zuhause für ihr
interesse unseren gästen natürlich hier
für die vielen fragen und ihnen herr
scholz verantworten
[Applaus]